bien
monsieur le ministre mis chers collègues
c'est avec plaisir monsieur le ministre
que nous recevons pour la première fois
le ministre délégué auprès du ministre
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
chargé des transports cette audition
nous offre l'opportunité d'échanger sur
les priorités du nouveau gouvernement en
matière de transport à l'aube de ce
quinquennat
d'abord je souhaiterais monsieur le
ministre rebondir sur une actualité
récente pour vous interroger sur un
sujet de préoccupation majeur pour notre
commission nous avons en effet un prix
de la semaine dernière le départ si
c'est pas un débarquement des fois de
Monsieur Luc Lallemand en fonction de
président directeur général de SNCF
réseau si communiqué de presse du
ministère de l'Économie préfère plus
sobrement évoquer une nouvelle étape
dans la feuille de route de SNCF réseau
et des transports cette situation ne
fait que renforcer nos inquiétudes quant
aux insuffisances du contrat de
performance en SNCF réseau donc on a
déjà eu l'occasion de discuter
contrat de performance sur lequel je
suppose vous serez interrogé car
l'inquiétude est grand
aussi Monsieur le Ministre est-ce que
vous serez possible de nous préciser si
cette nouvelle feuille de route sera
adossée à des moyens
supplémentaires pour le gestionnaire
d'infrastructures au-delà du seul mode
ferroviaire nous souhaiterions savoir
quels sont les principales priorités de
votre ministère en ce début de
quinquennat nous le savons les
investissements nécessaires en matière
d'infrastructures sont colossaux en
conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures coi
il est évoqué d'ailleurs un mur
d'investissement de 200 milliards
d'euros dans les 10 prochaines années
dans ce contexte monsieur le minis
seriez-vous favorable soit à réviser la
trajectoire de la loi d'orientation des
mobilités étant entendu que nous
arrivons bientôt au terme de la première
période trajectoire des dépenses
2019-2023
soit comme l'a évoqué le président
Jean-Pierre favendou devant notre
commission il y a quelques semaines en
réponse à une question de notre collègue
Olivier Jacquin a travaillé et à
l'élaboration d'une loi de programmation
des infrastructures
j'en viens au transport aérien qui a
connu d'importantes difficultés cet été
et qui est confronté au défi de sa
transition écologique la dame a publié
la semaine dernière un rapport
présentant trois scénarios pour une
transition écologique et identifiant 5
leviers des écarbonations parmi ceux-ci
le recours au carburant durable est une
piste privilégiée monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous dire où en est le
projet de développement d'une filière
française de production et comment
veiller à éviter des problématiques de
concurrence des usages de ces carburants
j'en viens à présent au disposition
consacrée au transport dans le PLF pour
l'exercice 2023 pour vous poser deux
questions la première porte sur
l'enveloppe consacrée aux
infrastructures et services de transport
si nous souhaitons l'augmentation des
moyens infectés à ce programme nous
souhaiterions obtenir des précisions
quand leur affectation aussi
pourriez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
éclairer sur ce point et nous indiquer
quelles sont les principales
orientations de ce budget pour les
différents modes de transport ma seconde
question porte sur le nouveau dispositif
des leasings sociales dont l'objectif
est de rendre accessible la location de
véhicules électriques pourriez-vous nous
en dire plus sur les modalités précises
de ce dispositif
ce matin nous avons organisé une table
ronde sur les véhicules électriques qui
a révélé que certains obstacles
déploiement à grande échelle de Murray
pourriez-vous nous indiquer quels sont
vos pistes de réflexion sur ce sujet en
outre ou en sont les travaux de la taxe
relatives à la transition énergétique du
transport routier de marchandises je
rappelle que nous attendions une dizaine
initialement les résultats en étant 2021
le minis sans plus attendre je vous
laisse la parole
pour
avant de la donner à mes collègues qui
me semblent tous vouloir poser des
questions en numéro 1 et donc on va
essayer de faire le mieux possible
merci monsieur le Président je vous
laisserai le la chance d'exercer cette
discipline je m’aventurerais pas sur ce
terrain je voulais monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs vous
remercier d'abord monsieur le Président
de nos premiers échanges qui ont été
rapides mais des ma prise de fonction au
début du mois de juillet avec plusieurs
de vos collègues et je voulais vous
remercier pour cette invitation et
première expression devant votre
commission au moment où va s'engager le
débat budgétaire devant le Parlement à
l'Assemblée nationale puis au Sénat et
où la question des mobilités que l'on
dit ou les transports sera évidemment
une des préoccupations importantes au
carrefour de beaucoup des débats du
moment en termes pardon de pouvoir
d'achat
de sobriété d'économie d'énergie et de
transition écologique sur le plus long
terme puisque nous le savons les
transports représentent 30% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
notre pays et à peu près autant en
termes de consommation d'énergie ça veut
dire que ça peut être un défi mais aussi
une chance parce que ce secteur est un
des vecteurs de nos efforts de sobriété
aujourd'hui mais surtout de nous
transformations pour la transition
écologique dans le domaine des mobilités
dans les années qui viennent alors comme
c'est la première fois que je m'exprime
je vais pas être trop long vous m'avez
invité la concision monsieur le
Président je n'abuserai pas mais je
voulais dire quelques mots avant de
rentrer dans les chiffres et d'essayer
de répondre aux questions que vous avez
déjà mentionné sur une orientation
générale de politique publique dans le
secteur des transports je souhaite
porter trois grandes priorités dont le
PLF est un premier reflet je l'ai dit à
plusieurs reprises
la question de la modernisation et de la
régénération de notre réseau ferré la
première ministre est l'occasion de le
dire lors de sa déclaration de politique
générale et ici Bruno Le Maire en son
nom le transport ferroviaire et la
colonne vertébrale de la mobilité verte
et la colonne vertébrale de la colonne
vertébrale c'est vraiment le réseau nous
avons parfois tendance à ne pas le voir
à ne pas le voir ces difficultés nous
avons parfois aussi tendance à
sous-estimer nos investissements
collectifs car il n'appartient pas qu'à
l'état dans le secteur ferroviaire je
crois que nous n'avons pas à rougir sur
ce sujet en question en comparaison
pardon européenne mais nous avons en
effet une difficulté spécifique qui est
l'âge de notre réseau un
réinvestissement important a été porté
ces dernières années il est passé de
moins de 2,5 milliards d'euros par an à
un contrat de performance vous l'avez
cité nous y reviendrons certainement de
2,9 milliards d'euros par an sur les 10
prochaines années c'est un changement
majeur quand on sait qu'il y a 15 ans
nous étions à un milliard d'euros par an
d'investissement à notre réseau ferré
donc nous avons pris du retard nous le
rattrapons et sans doute nous devons
aller encore plus loin et encore plus
vite mais j'insiste vraiment sur cette
priorité et elle est en partie retracée
dans les éléments budgétaires j'y
reviendrai dans le budget de la fixe qui
sera voté en fin d'année
monsieur le Président vous avez évoqué
la question en janvier un mot par
cohérence maintenant des SNCF réseau
la question des personnes n'est pas la
seule évidemment c'est d'abord la
question des moyens près de leur
mobilisation qui compte nous l'avons
appelé mais je pense qu'il était
important en effet d'ouvrir ou l'avait
rappelé ainsi un nouveau chapitre ce
sont les expressions que nous avons
utilisées avec le ministre de l'Économie
monsieur Luc allemand a mené un effort
de rétablissement financier très
important et je crois que dans la
relation avec les régions au moment où
nous devons réinvestir encore davantage
et déployer le contrat de performance
voir aller au delà mettre en place j'y
reviendrai une nouvelle programmation
était important d'avoir aussi une
nouvelle impulsion à la tête de SMCF
réseau ce qui marque aussi l'importance
que nous y portons et Monsieur Chabanel
qui était proposé qui sera sans doute
bientôt formellement désigné comme
président des SNCF réseau et je crois
aujourd'hui
sans doute l'un des meilleurs
connaisseurs dans son lien avec les
collectivités locales dans son lien avec
les équipes dans sa connaissance ces
projets de notre réseau ferré donc je
rends hommage à lucle allemand et je
pense que nous avons besoin de cette
nouvelle impulsion aussi deuxième axe
très important pour le dire très
rapidement vous êtes trop rapidement les
transports du quotidien cela recouvre
des réalités qui sont diverses d'un
territoire à l'autre les transports du
quotidien ça n'est pas réservé aux
grandes agglomérations et aux grandes
villes en revanche je crois qu'il faut
assumer que nos types de priorité ne
seront pas exactement les mêmes selon la
nature du territoire et des besoins de
mobilité dans les grandes agglomérations
les transports publics les transports
ferrés en particulier sont évidemment
une solution prioritaire il y a nous
avons l'occasion de l'évoquer dans ma
réponse au sénateur Boyer un certain
nombre de lignes qui sont aussi d'une
certaine façon les transports du
quotidien de l'une d'équilibre du
territoire Paris Clermont-Ferrand Paul
Tenfant parti parce que ce sont des
liaisons économiquement vitales et que
nous devons rénover je n'y reviens pas
ici en détail mais nous pourrions venir
dans notre échange et puis ça veut dire
aussi que dans la statue de ou par
définition plus rurale plus enclavée une
offre de transport public de même nature
de même disponibilité n'est pas
envisageable de la même condition que
dans une grande agglomération très dense
nous devons aussi assumer que la voiture
fait partie des solutions
85 % des déplacements totaux en France
se font par la route pour les loisirs
comme pour le travail ça ne disparaîtra
pas d'un coup de baguette magique ce que
nous devons cibler ça n'est pas la
voiture en tant que tel c'est la voiture
individuelle et polluante et donc le
passage notamment aux véhicules
électriques vous avez parlé de
dispositif de leasing social dont les
premiers crédits sont bien prévus dans
le PLF qui commencera à se déployer en
2023 mais qui montrait en puissance qui
complète des dispositifs existants prime
à la conversion bonus malus etc pour
favoriser la démocratisation du véhicule
électrique sont essentiels pour
l'accessibilité la mobilité de tous
notamment dans les zones rurales et donc
je voudrais aussi qu'on change un peu
cette perception que le véhicule
électrique serait une sorte de solution
pour privilégier et pour centre ville ça
doit être ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui mais ça doit être aussi une
solution essentielle pour des ménages
modestes et pour les zones rurales parce
qu'on ne fera pas l'économie de la
voiture en soi dans des zones où il y a
moins de transport public par dans par
construction et par densité si je peux
dire et puis j'insiste sur évidemment
l'action la priorité transversale qui
est la question de la décarbonation de
nos modes de transport cela doit
irriguer si je puis le dire ainsi tous
nos modes de transport j'insiste parce
qu'évidemment cela veut dire des
changements d'usage et du report modal
notamment de la voiture de la voiture
individuelle et polluante comme je le
disais vers les transports publics à
chaque fois que c'est possible ou vers
des modes plus propres à chaque fois que
c'est possible mais ça veut dire qu'au
sein de ces modes la voiture par
électrique ou l'aviation par exemple il
y a aussi un potentiel de décarbonation
la décarbonation ça n'est pas simplement
mais ça n'est pas éliminer les modes de
transport c'est aussi verdir des modes
de transport qui aujourd'hui contribue à
nos émissions la voiture parce qu'elle
représente j'y reviens 85% des
déplacements et l'aviation parce qu'on
va pas supprimer l'avion à l'évidence
nous avons une filière industrielle nous
avions besoin réels j'y reviendrons
peut-être dans les échanges j'y tiens en
tant que les transports et en tant que
membre d'un gouvernement qui porte une
politique industrielle et je pense que
nous devons changer nos usages verdir là
aussi notre industrie et nos appareils
et
avoir des règles internationales
européennes qui poussent ce mode de
transport vers la décarbonation mais
j'insiste tous les modes de transport
contribuent à la décarbonation ça n'est
pas simplement un jeu de transfert de
l'un à l'autre même si évidemment
je reprends pas les mots que j'utilisais
sur la colonne vertébrale le report vers
le ferroviaire le plus possible et une
des solutions clés à notre nécessité de
transition écologique
je fais peut-être un zoom si je puis
dire sur quelques éléments chiffrés
puisque après tout nous parlons quand
même du budget pour 2023 vous le savez
mieux que personne pour suivre ce budget
beaucoup d'entre vous de longue date et
en détail il n'est pas tout à fait
facile de restituer les formes
budgétaires globales nationales d'abord
en matière de transport puisque c'est
une compétence largement partagée mais
même l'effort de l'État n'est pas
totalement évident à reconstituer et
n'est pas refléter par le seul programme
budgétaire qui est consacré au transport
le programme 203 et donc je vais essayer
très rapidement sans être trop détaillé
je pourrais le préciser ensuite de
retracer cet effort d'ensemble cette
effort d'ensemble il est environ 12
milliards d'euros en PLF pour 2023 le
PLF qui vous est proposé c'est une
augmentation importante de 15% par
rapport à 2022 et si je détaille les
choses de manière un petit peu plus
spécifique il y a bien sûr ce programme
203 qui porte au sein de la mission
écologie
le budget est transports dont j'ai la
responsabilité vous m'avez interrogé sur
ce point monsieur le Président sur les
12 milliards d'euros ce sont plus le la
moitié qui sont consacrés au transport
ferroviaire et collectif et dans le
budget sans strict le programme de 103
ce sont les trois quarts des crédits qui
sont consacrés au mode de transport
ferroviaire notamment au financement des
ressources du réseau si on veut être
complet il faut donc ajouter à ces 4,1
milliard d'euros pardon du budget du
programme 203 les 3,8 milliards d'euros
qui sont prévus aujourd'hui dans le
budget de la fixe comme vous le savez le
budget de la fuite est voté un peu plus
tard en fin d'année il sera largement
consacré aussi au transport ferroviaire
par rapport à la trajectoire qui était
prévue par la loi d'orientation des
mobilités la première ministre a bien
voulu arbitrer pour le PLF une
augmentation de 150 millions d'euros en
crédit de paiement dans la première
action sera un complément de financement
pour la modernisation du réseau
ferroviaire au-delà du contrat de
performance pour donner ce premier
signal avant d'autres rendez-vous sur
lesquels je reviens dans un instant il
faut ajouter à cet effort 4,1 milliard
d'euros dans le programme de 103 3,8
milliards d'euros pour la fuite
plusieurs actions très importantes c'est
près de 1 milliard d'euros qui sont
consacrés à la Société du Grand Paris
pour des infrastructures de transport en
Île-de-France c'est 200 millions d'euros
même 250 millions d'euros qui sont
consacrés à voie navigable de France
au-delà des ressources budgétaires c'est
un budget de l'aviation civile qui
atteint 800 millions d'euros
principalement pour le contrôle et la
sécurité aérien
et dans le domaine aérien toujours
puisque nous parlions de décarbonation
c'est un effort de 500 millions d'euros
qui se poursuit notamment à travers le
coracle pour financer la recherche et
l'innovation notre excellence
industrielle que nous devons maintenir
en matière d'aviation civile si elle
ajoute un projet spécifique un peu
particulier mais je le cite parce que
fait partie cet effort 0,4 milliards 400
millions d'euros pour les ressources les
avances consenties au projet Charles de
Gaulle express pour retracer tout cela
il faut ajouter enfin
milliards d'euros c'est la Poste qui est
en plus gros en plus forte augmentation
pardon pour les moyens consacrés au
verdissements du parc automobile et qui
regroupe le bonus malus la prime à la
conversion et les premiers crédits qui
seront développés déployés par nous en
2023 au titre du dispositif de leasing
social qui sera défini dans les
prochaines semaines les paramètres ne
sont pas encore arrêtés il faut en effet
déployer progressivement parce que cela
prendra l'évidence du temps une filière
de production européenne et surtout
française et il y aura le premier crédit
il y a de premier crédit pour
crédibiliser cet engagement qui sont
mises en place dans le PLF pour le 2023
est soumis donc à votre vote
je dis un dernier mot deux derniers mots
pardon pour être le plus complet
possible monsieur le Président en
réponse à deux questions je n'ai pas
encore évoqué l'une très rapidement sur
l'aviation vous m'avez demandé quand
est-ce que nous déployons une filière de
production notamment de carburant propre
pour avoir une filière il faut un signal
clair pour montrer que ce besoin va
exister qui aura une demande en face
nous savons aujourd'hui que ce qui fait
que les safs notamment ces fameux
carburants propres ou plus propre ne
sont que peu développés c'est que il y a
pas en amont la production suffisante
parce qu'en réalité nos avionneurs sont
capables d'avoir des taux
d'incorporation très élevés et les
compagnies aériennes n'y sont pas
opposées même si les coûts sont plus
importants parce qu'elles envoient bien
la nécessité nous avons une discussion
européenne nous pourrons revenir je le
dis d'un mot d'un texte qui s'appelle
pardon pour l'anglicisme rifuel et qui
fixera pour 2025 pour 2030 et au-delà
c'est peut-être que c'est encore en
discussion des cibles d'incorporation
commune à tous les États européens à
tous les aéroports parce que c'est pas
eux que la règle passera européen pour
que nous incorporions progressivement
sans l'outil pour cent de cibles sera
fixée en 2030 obligatoirement ces
carburants propres je pense que nous
devons sans doute aller d'ailleurs
au-delà ensuite revoir ces cibles à la
hausse pour donner un signal aux
producteurs sans se signal les
producteurs ne se lanceront pas dans cet
effort plus industriel et plus massif de
production et encore une fois le reste
de la filière est prête les avionneurs
sont prêts pour l'aviation privée comme
pour l'aviation commerciale en général
et les aéroports sont prêts à déployer
aussi les infrastructures nécessaires à
ces carburants vous m'avez interrogé
monsieur le Président et ça me permet de
conclure sur quelques éléments de
calendriers sur la programmation ou
l'actualisation de la programmation
c'est évidemment un sujet clé le conseil
d'orientation les infrastructures et je
veux saluer les membres du Sénat qui en
feront partie mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs Tabaro Herzog Dagbert ce
travail je commencerai à l'installer je
l'installerai plus exactement pour la
phase finale du rapport en fin de
semaine
vous rendrez je crois je l'espère par
échange avec le président Valence d'ici
sans doute la fin du mois de novembre ou
le début du mois de décembre et c'est
important parce que sur cette base à
partir de cet éclairage nous pourrons
définir une programmation plus réelle
qui sera nécessaire parce que la
dernière date de la l'homme elle reste
essentielle mais elle doit être
actualisée il y a des efforts qui ont
été faits par exemple dans le point de
relance les protocoles petites lignes
qui doivent être intégrés des coûts qui
sont mieux estimés sur les grands
projets type Lyon Turin ou canon Senn
Nord donc nous aurons besoin l'évidence
une actualisation de la programmation ce
que je ne peux vous dire aujourd'hui car
le gouvernement n'a pas encore arrêté ce
qui sera sa position et attend aussi le
contenu des travaux du coi c'est est-ce
que cela prendra une forme législative
d'une nouvelle loi de l'orientation ou
pas je ne peux pas le dire aujourd'hui
mais il faudra bien sûr compléter et
actualiser cette programmation à
l'évidence donc rapport du coi
cela enclenchera aussi un travail très
attendu je le sais les nouvelles volet
mobilité de nouvelles génération de
contrats de planétarium nous avons pris
du retard nous devons donc sans tarder
ouvrir la négociation entre l'État et
les régions et les autres collectivités
concernées de ces contrats et c'est sur
la base du rapport ou de l'éclairage du
coi nous pourrons procéder et je
souhaite comme je l'ai indiqué la région
de France pouvoir le faire d'ici la fin
pour signature finalisée d'ici la fin du
premier semestre 2023 je le redis aussi
ici comme je l'ai dit devant région de
France il n'y aura pas d'année blanche
et donc en attendant la signature de ces
nouveaux volets mobilités de ces
contrats de plan à l'été prochain au
tout début de l'été prochain
et bien les crédits pour les projets
engagés seront maintenus et les
financements CPE en 2023 ne seront
jamais inférieures au niveau qui a été
programmé exécuté en 2022 nous avons
besoin de donner cette visibilité à tous
mais notamment nos partenaires des
collectivités et singulièrement des
régions
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez
déjà anticipé
en répondant à deux questions qui
voulaient vous poser mais vous mes
collègues m'ont dit j'ai la réponse
merci donc je vais donner la parole à
Philippe tavaro
merci président monsieur le ministre je
vais essayer d'être très synthétique et
très clair pour une fois certains
collègues c'est ça Pascal merci
s'il vous plaît la même franchise pour
pour répondre nous sommes un certain
nombre dans cette commission à demander
des moyens supplémentaires pour nos
infrastructures notamment ferroviaires
face aux investissements chroniques dans
notre pays depuis des années un
sous-investissement qui va s'accroître
si vous ne revoyez pas le contrat de
performance signé avec réseau pendant
l'élection présidentielle notamment au
moment où l'Italie annonce 120 milliards
d'euros d'investissement l'Allemagne 86
milliards en disant alors vous pouvez
changer annuellement de présidente de
SNCF réseau mais si vous ne donnez pas
les moyens supplémentaires pour
régénérer moderniser notre réseau cela
ne changera rien
concrètement alors je sais que c'est
compliqué à l'exercice et difficile vous
avez donné un certain nombre de sommes
mais on aimerait clairement comprendre
qu'est-ce que vous arrivez à dégager en
plus sur le PLF sur les infrastructures
ferroviaires comme vous l'avez dit afin
de respecter la signature de l'État dans
les différentes conventions et dans ce
qui reste des CPER ou dans les futurs
CPER et de sauver nos lignes
ferroviaires
et s'il vous plaît alors vous l'avez pas
fait totalement là mais ne répondez pas
comme à l'Assemblée nationale que vous
attendez exclusivement les travaux du
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures ce qui est plutôt
valorisant pour les membres ici présents
mais vous connaissez très bien les
priorités SNCF réseau vous savez très
bien que pour éviter par exemple la
fermeture des 9000 km de de
petites lignes sur notre territoire il
faut investir pour lever les
ralentissements sur près de 5000 km de
de ces mêmes voies ferrées il faut des
investissements que mettre en place le
rTMS de préférence avant la Lituanie
pour ne pas avoir le bonnet d'âne
européen ce serait bien également donc
monsieur vous l'avez très justement dit
également le mur d'investissement il est
devant nous et si vous tergiverser allez
on va se mettre tous ensemble si on
tergiverse on va se le prendre en pleine
face donc voilà sur cette question et
permettez-moi juste un petit mot sur la
question du financement des transports
je veux savoir quelle Clément bonne j'ai
en face de moi est-ce que on a celui qui
a dit aux régions de France à Vichy
qu'il va partager avec eux le versement
mobilité ou celui qui a Lyon devant le
garde affirme aux autorités
organisatrices de mobilité que le VM est
sanctuarisé à leur profit merci
merci chers collègues j'ai donné la
parole à Olivier Jacquin
ée
totalement aux propos de Philippe Tabaro
sur le contrat de performance SNCF
réseau alors rapporteur pour avis sur
les transports routiers le premier des
trois thèmes que j'aborderai vous vous
en doutez sera celui des autoroutes sur
France Info le 23 septembre vous disiez
refuser la hausse des tarifs des péages
au niveau de l'inflation telle que
proposée par les autoroutiers sur la
base des contrats de concession
préférant une option à seulement 5%.
pouvez-vous nous dire où en sont les
négociations et quels sont les termes
précis du débat avec eux cette moindre
hausse se fera-t-elle en échange d'un
allongement des questions première
question ce qui était une ligne rouge
absolue des conclusions de notre
commission dans quatre sénatoriales et
plus généralement deuxième question où
en sont les réflexions gouvernementales
sur l'avenir des concessions une fois
les contrats arrivés à leur terme
également sur leur routier des régions
avaient jusqu'au 30 septembre pour
notifier la volonté de transfert de
route dans les conditions prévues par la
loi 3DS la région Grand Est délibérant
ce sens le 23 septembre mais à souligné
le manque d'éléments notamment
financiers permettant de valider
définitivement cette démarche nous
sommes un effet toujours en attente de
la publication de l'ordonnance ecotax de
la loi climat donc troisième question
pouvez-vous nous dire où en est sa
rédaction et quelle modalités sont
retenues quatrième question par ailleurs
est-il envisageable d'allonger les
durées des expérimentations des
transferts afin que les régions
bénéficient de cette ressource pour
stabiliser l'opération financièrement je
vais gagner du temps je ne vais pas
évoquer la deuxième thématique le
leasing social vous avez apporté
malheureusement suffisamment d'éléments
de réponse en ne pouvant pas nous
préciser encore
substantiellement les dispositifs je
peux le comprendre mais je tenais
beaucoup car cette idée géniale a été
portée par une autre candidate pendant
la campagne et judicieusement reprise
par Emmanuel Macron
alors plus rapidement sur le ferroviaire
et en complément de Philippe Tabaro
trois questions sans revenir sur le
contrat de performance SNCF réseau vous
nous avez précisé que vous étiez j'aime
bien entendu vous alliez attendre le
rapport du coi pour voir s'il y aurait
ou non une nouvelle loi de programmation
donc
pouvez-vous être encore un petit peu
plus précis que ça notamment sur
l'aspect qui a relevé Philippe Tabarro
sur le sous-investissement chronique
chez SNCF réseau et dans le réseau
indépendamment d'une loi de
programmation il y a besoin d'un coup de
pouce c'est ça que nous souhaitons un
peu plus un coup de pouce quoi peut-être
pas les 100 milliards de farandoux mais
pas des 2,8 milliards actuels deuxième
question le Sénat avait voté la baisse
du taux de TVA sur les billets de train
à 5,5% lors de la loi climat contre la
vie du gouvernement avez-vous changé de
position une question sur un sujet local
le TGV direct Nancy Lyon vit à Dijon a
été supprim en 2018 une alternative via
Marne-la-Vallée a été créée mais a subi
le même sort du fait de la crise covid
et n'est jamais revenu le gouvernement a
publié il y a 15 mois un rapport sur les
trains d'équilibre du territoire ce
rapport a démontré l'utilité la
nécessité de rétablir une liaison
directe de jours et de nuit entraînant
si et Lyon via Dijon 8e question
pouvez-vous nous faire un point d'étape
de la déclinaison de ce rapport et
particulièrement de la desserte sud de
Nancy le nouveau pacte ferroviaire de
2018 n'obligeant plus la SNCF à
reprendre ce service sous la forme TGV
selon Jean-Pierre farandoux dernier
thème le versement mobilité puisque le
sujet a de nouveau été remis sur la
table ces derniers jours
donc neuvième question êtes-vous
favorable à l'instauration d'un
versement mobilité à taux réduit dans
les espaces peu dense qui en sont
dépourvus afin de leur permettre de se
doter d'une ingénierie et de développer
des solutions de mobilité comme je le
préconise dans mon rapport de janvier
2021 sur les mobilités dans les espaces
peu denses et comme l'avait le Sénat
avait voté uneaniement dans la lame et
enfin je termine alors que vous comptez
supprimer de nouveau 8 milliards d'euros
d'un pot de production dans le PLF sans
contrepartie dernière question ne
serait-il pas opportun de faire
contribuer en petite compensation de
cette suppression l'ensemble des
entreprises au versement mobilité on a
descend voir en supprimant le seuil
d'agi d'un sujet permettant donc
d'augmenter l'enveloppe et de distribuer
du vm aux régions sans pénaliser les
intercours ceci afin de développer et
renforcer l'offre de mobilité là où elle
existe déjà
merci
je vais dans la parole Évelyne Perrot
monsieur le ministre
Sion à propos des mobilités aériennes
sur votre positionnement vis-à-vis d'un
secteur pris entre des tendances
contradictoires effectivement en plein
ma race sanitaire économique et aérien
j'avais évoqué plusieurs fois le désir
sous-jacent de voyage de revanche et
c'est exactement ce qu'on a pu constater
cet été or en Europe et aux États-Unis
les opérateurs avaient réduit la voilure
pour survivre financièrement et ils ont
eu ensuite de sérieuses difficultés de
recrutement en tout cas cette pression
de la demande a été le principal facteur
de la hausse du prix des billets d'avion
qui s'expliquent également par la montée
du prix du kérosène en sens contraire on
perçoit un frein sociétal et
environnemental ainsi que des décisions
européennes dont la complexité se résume
à une augmentation de la taxation
carbone vous avez donné tout à l'heure
quelques chiffres si vous pouvez nous
les répéter pour que je puisse contrôler
si j'ai bien noté ensuite
je voulais vous parler des filières
biocérosène et ich kérosène trop
balbutiante dans notre pays où en est-on
sur ce point par rapport à nos voisins
européens et par rapport aux États-Unis
je rappelle que l'Allemagne développe le
captage de CO2 pour en faire du
carburant et que les avions aux
États-Unis fonctionnent de plus en plus
à l'huile usagée deuxièmement le bruit
dans nos territoires la sensibilité de
nos concitoyens au décibels de l'aérien
c'est accrue estimez-vous que la
réglementation française est d'ores et
déjà une des plus sévères du monde ou
alors êtes-vous favorable à l'idée de
légiférer pour accroître les pouvoirs de
l'autorité indépendante de contrôle des
nuisances aéroportuaires et améliorer la
vélocité des procédures certains se
demandent si le silence des voitures
électriques va permettre de réconcilier
l'automobile avec les autophobes mais
pour l'aviation l'électrification n'est
envisageable que pour les tout petits
appareils
je souhaitais aussi aborder la question
médiatique des jets privés on en compte
d’après les chiffres dont je dispose
moins de 200 immatriculées en France et
je rappelle que juridiquement cette
notion est floue inexistante mais qu'on
retrouve la césure entre les partisans
de l'interdiction taxation et ceux du
verdissement merci merci
[Musique]
la première monsieur du ministre
concerne le report des poids lourds en
transit des autoroutes vers les réseaux
secondaires que sont les groupes
nationales
et ce afin de ne pas payer les
autoroutes et de profiter d'un réseau
secondaire non adapté mais gratuit
parfois plus court ce qui est le cas
d'ailleurs dans mon département la
Charente avec la route nationale 10 qui
supporte un trafic de plus de 10000
poids lourds jour dont plus de 50% de
trafic international je vous laisse
imaginer les conséquences très négatives
qui sont nombreuses et qui vont
croissantes ce phénomène existe dans
beaucoup de départements j'ai évoqué la
question à plusieurs reprises avec votre
prédécesseur notre commission a évoqué
ce sujet et a fait plusieurs
propositions sérieuses dont le dépôt
d'une proposition de loi avec des
éléments comme la mise en oeuvre d'une
cartographie nationale de ce que nous
appelons nous c'est les itinéraires de
fuite la consultation des acteurs
concernés
sous l'égide du préfet pour trouver sur
le terrain les leviers de réduction des
nuisances la renforcement du pouvoir des
élus avec la création de dispositifs
nouveaux de réduction des zones de
réduction de nuisances sur le modèle des
et des feux l'interdiction des poids
lourds sur les routes nationales ou les
départementales lorsqu'il y a à
proximité une autoroute le retour de
l'écotaxe etc nombre de propositions à
ce jour Monsieur le Ministre rien de
sérieux n'a été partagé n'a été proposé
et donc je vous demande solennellement
de bien vouloir entendre le Sénat le
travail qu'il a fait est d'accepter de
mener une expérimentation sur la route
nationale 10 par exemple mais ça peut
être ailleurs pour tenir compte de la
réalité surtout apporter les bonnes
réponses ça c'est ma première alerte la
deuxième alerte concerne le transport
scolaire je suis présidente nationale
une association qui s'appelle la natep
qui œuvre depuis 1964 pour
l'amélioration du transport scolaire et
du transport collectif de jeunes et je
voudrais monsieur le ministre que vous
me confirmiez la position du
gouvernement sur la règle du transport
assis des élèves dans les transports en
commun pourquoi je vous demande ça parce
que face à la pénurie des conducteurs
certains souhaitent qu'on puisse revenir
sur cette règle en mettant les enfants
dans les bus plutôt que dans des cas ce
qui leur permettrait de dégager des
personnels de conduite à l'heure ou des
enfants ont été grièvement blessés dans
un accident dans la périphérie de Laval
parce qu'ils étaient illégalement debout
dans un bus revenir sur la règle du
transport assis serait un retour en
arrière très dommageable donc je
voudrais monsieur le ministre que vous
nous donniez la position du Gouvernement
sur ce sujet important et vous en
rajoutant que par ailleurs nous
attendons la circulaire conjointe de la
djtm et de la DSR pour rappeler le texte
et l'esprit de la loi sur ce sujet merci
pour vos réponses
merci Madame Bonnefoy sur cette question
ces questions et la première je dois
rencontrer le ministre socio le même
problématique sur la 83 chez moi et sur
effectivement l'utilisation de
l'autoroute pour des engorger la
nationale je vais dans la Martinique
merci
président
vous le savez les récents incidences sur
le RER B et D en pleine canicule
inquiète profondément notamment sur la
capacité de la France à cuire des
millions de spectateurs à l'occasion de
de la coupe du rugby l'année prochaine
et les JO en 2024 et en plus évidemment
des usagers au quotidien de nos
transports en commun
l'État se doit d'être aux côtés
d'Île-de-France mobilité et se doit
d'animer le dialogue le dialogue
interrégional en matière de transport
d'autant plus que les besoins financiers
seront importants cela a déjà été
rappelé je pense notamment à
l'articulation entre la région Normandie
et Île-de-France ces dernières subit la
suppression de train direct entre
Mantes-la-Jolie dans les Yvelines qui
est mon département et Paris
Saint-Lazare des trains opérés par la
région normande donc ma question sur ce
volet là monsieur le ministre c'est le
volet transport du contrat du plan état
région qui faisait pas partie du CPER
initiale comprendra-t-il un engagement
financier ambitieux du gouvernement et
le gouvernement compte-t-il s'engager
dans le dialogue interrégional des
transports aux côtés des régions
volontaires ma deuxième question portera
sur la lutte contre les nuisances liées
au transport ferroviaire la l'homme qui
a été rapporté chez nous par notre
collègue Monsieur Didier mandeli a prévu
une révision des normes sur les
nuisances sonores prenant en compte la
fréquence des passages et
l'établissement de normes en matière de
pollution vibratoire les transports du
quotidien comme les grandes lignes sont
concernées nous avons tous dans nos
circonscriptions des exemples en la
matière pas plus tard que la semaine
dernière j'étais interpellée par les
élus de quatre communes différentes des
Yvelines à ce sujet une véritable
politique publique unifiée en la matière
serait donc la bienvenue ma question
monsieur le ministre comptez-vous bâtir
une véritable politique publique en la
matière avec des moyens dédiés et
[Musique]
que globalement sur les 15 ans à venir
on il faudrait sans doute atteindre
quelque chose de cet ordre là on
investissement c'est un chemin exigeant
qu'il faut engager dès cette année et
qui est à planifier par une loi de
programmation pour les années à venir
donc comment Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous parvenir à nous mettre sur
ce chemin d'un nouvel essor ferroviaire
qui laisse derrière lui ce
sous-investissement chronique encore sur
le ferroviaire je m'interroge et vous
interroge donc sur la sur la viabilité
la pertinence du lion Turin je serai
court en polarisant uniquement sur deux
soucis celui des impacts sur la
ressource en eau dont les premiers
percements montreraient qu'il pourrait
être d'une gravité difficilement
tolérable ne pourrait-il pas s'assurer
de la conformité au regard de la loi sur
l'eau regardez les nouveaux éléments et
deuxième souci celui du financement vous
avez parlé il y a un instant du coût
sous-estimé de ce grand projet au moment
où vous semblez pencher pour le scénario
d'accès le plus coûteux et alors que à
ma connaissance
le financement européen sur lequel vous
comptez tant ne semble pas aussi
concrètement garantie
et je vais donner la parole à Monsieur
laelec et puis après même Sempé à
Monsieur blanc et puis on aura fini la
première série de questions pour prendre
une deuxième situation
allez-y cherche merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur le Premier
Ministre et merci d'avoir bien voulu
rappeler que
ça va venir ça va venir
donc merci merci d'avoir rappelé que le
ferroviaire et la colonne vertébrale de
la mobilité verte c'est une opinion à
mon avis que nous partageons
majoritairement ici il est bien de
l'avoir rappelé je reviendrai pas trop
longuement non plus sur le départ
inattendu de Monsieur l'allemand
peut-être a-t-il été difficile pour lui
de promouvoir la qualité du contrat de
performance ce que je peux comprendre
mais comme le dit votre communiqué on
retiendra de lui ce qu'il a fait de bien
donc voilà donc il faut maintenant se
tourner se tourner vers l'avenir
et en se tournant vers l'avenir avant on
a besoin d'une grande ambition d'une
grande ambition publique d'une grande
ambition budgétaire
et monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi de vous dire
que dans ce contexte un peu compliqué
lourd parfois l'ambiance n'est pas
toujours terrible
vous avez une chance inouïe
je ne vous la prends pas je suppose
mais vous avez une chance inouïe parce
que
vous disposez d'une majorité politique
pour faire plus et pour faire mieux
je me réfère là aux différents rapports
qui ont été produits ici au Sénat
je me réfère là au rapport qui ont été
produits au moment du débat sur la loi
climat qui m'a énergie
et je me réfère à un certain nombre
d'autres rapports d'autocésines qui ont
pu être produit ici
ce qui veut dire qu'il y a de fait une
majorité politique pour tendre à
affirmer une ambition publique pour le
développement du ferroviaire c'est quand
même quelque chose d'assez singulier et
d'assez intéressant quand il s'agit de
se tourner vers l'avenir et puis à ça
s'ajoute le fait quand même que
l'ancien Premier ministre
est aujourd'hui président de la fuite
c'est que c'est quand même un atout du
point de vue du développement des
transports et de leur financement et
puis monsieur le ministre je me suis
laissé dire que vous aviez l'oreille
attentive de monsieur le Président de la
République ce qui n'est pas le moindre à
tout
par conséquent au regard de tout ce qui
a été produit je ne reviens pas sur la
TVA 5,5 sur tout ce qui a été produit au
regard de tout ça
il ne dépend plus que de vous
d'engager la mise en oeuvre de cette
ambition publique autour de laquelle de
fait un consensus politique existe dans
notre pays et donc la question que je
vous pose c'est
êtes-vous prêt à vous saisir de ce
consensus dynamique pour faire en sorte
que le ferroviaire affiche une ambition
nouvelle de développement
bien
après la description après la
description de tous ces atouts je vais
donner la parole de Nissan et puis à
Monsieur blanc et puis après monsieur le
ministre vous allez carton même sur le
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre si nous sommes conscients au
Sénat depuis longtemps de l'impératif de
la transition écologique celle-ci n'a
n’est devenue que plus pressante au vu
des manifestations extrêmes du
changement climatique que nous avons
tous vu cet été à travers notre pays
pour cela il nous faut entre autres des
carboner les transports secteurs
responsables d'environ un tiers des
émissions de CO2 en France à ce titre
des investissements massifs dans le
ferroviaire sont nécessaires vous ne
l'avez précisé cependant l'état fait
face à deux injonctions très lourdes en
la matière puisqu'il faut rénover les
lignes existantes pour favoriser les
trains du quotidien sans renoncer pour
autant à son ambition de développer les
lignes grande vitesse
le risque évidemment est qu'à vouloir
atteindre ces deux objectifs aucun ne
soit véritablement atteint le
gouvernement pense-t-il être en mesure
de faire ce en même temps si oui comment
en ce qui concerne de plus près mon
territoire pouvez-vous m'en dire plus
sur l'avancement du GPSO je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur blanc oui très brièvement
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur on
est un peu surpris de ne pas vous avoir
entendu spontanément aborder la question
du financement du lion Turin qui vient
de vous être à payer il y a quelques
minutes pourtant c'est un dossier
absolument essentiel et d'abord parce
que l'Europe vient de prendre un acte
d'exécution se plaignant un peu du fait
que la France prenait du retard et puis
ensuite parce que c'est un manquement à
nos engagements internationaux notamment
vis-à-vis de l'Italie qui prend de
l'avance sur nous j'aimerais vous
entendre sur ce sujet là les
collectivités territoriales
sous l'autorité du préfet de région mais
en tout cas l'initiative du préfet de
région on fait un choix très clair sur
les tracés sur les tunnels sur les
modalités de réalisation de ce de cette
liaison et donc nous aimerions vous
entendre sur les engagements du
gouvernement le montant des financements
et puis surtout sur les délais parce
qu'aujourd'hui les Italiens nous mettent
un peu au pied du mur je veux dire au
pied des Alpes
ce ministre
vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
vais essayer d'être le plus complet
possible tout en laissant du temps pour
la salve de questions suivantes en
commençant puisque c'était la question
peut-être la plus générique je peux le
dire ainsi par les interrogations de
Monsieur sénateur tabaco je vous rassure
on ne
toujours bon d'avoir quelques idées
avant même de recevoir aussi
éclairant soit-il le rapport du coi je
le crois l'avoir dit en termes peut-être
trop rapide mais sur la priorité de nos
réseaux bien sûr de nos transports du
quotidien vous m'avez interrogé plus
spécifiquement sur quelques points le
rTMS qui fait partie pour moi de la
modernisation du réseau et qui est une
obligation européenne en effet à la fois
le projet ERTMS et le projet comment le
centraliser du réseau CCR
nécessite des investissements massifs
pour lesquels nous solliciterons
d'ailleurs aussi des financements
européens qui pour une large partie
d'entre eux sont des investissements
j'allais dire au sens strict dans le
sens où il y a un retour sur
investissement notamment la possibilité
d'économiser un certain nombre de
dépenses ou de poste actuel
on va néanmoins bénéficier de
l'éclairage du coi sur la liste des
priorités le réseau pour moi je le dis
déjà même en attendant le rapport sera
très prioritaire je veux quand même dire
un mot du contrat de performance parce
que je pense pas qu'il méritent
tant d'indignité si je peux dire un
commentaire qui en est parfois fait je
n'étais pas là à ce moment-là mais je me
mets dans ses pas
il comporte un investissement qui n'a
jamais été réalisé ces quatre dernières
décennies de 2,9 milliards d'euros par
an sur 10 ans qu'on peut je vais venir
tout de suite dire qu'il faut aller plus
loin enfin c'est un effort qu'on n'a
jamais fait sur le réseau si on tient
cet effort pendant 10 ans on sera sans
doute en mesure et enfin on loue la
partager avec vous au moins de
stabiliser l'âge du réseau ce qui est
une rupture avec une tendance de
dégradation préoccupante depuis de
longues années je veux quand même dire à
cette occasion aussi puisque le point
était souligné et puis plusieurs d'entre
vous ont juste titre parler d'ambition
ferroviaire je le redis mais je pense
que c'est comme très important que le
constat soit clair et partagé nous ne
sommes pas un pays du
sous-investissement ferroviaire
j'insiste nous sommes encore en Europe
et je crois qu'on doit être
collectivement fier et ça n'est pas moi
qui l'ai engendré dans ces trois
derniers mois ni même l'État qui le
porte seul puisque les régions les
collectivités le port d'hébergement nous
avons dans le transport ferroviaire en
particulier un investissement qui est
tout à fait comparable et même supérieur
à celui beaucoup de pays européens si on
met boutaboul tous les financements et
d'ailleurs il y a peu de comparaisons
extrêmement récente ou extrêmement
fiables mais ce qu'on voit c'est que sur
les investissements publics les
infrastructures publiques la France est
encore très au dessus aujourd'hui de nos
voisins allemands espagnols italiens
même allemand alors là vous avez raison
c'est pour ça que j'insiste sur cette
priorité du réseau c'est que sur le
réseau spécifiquement nous avons un âge
moyen qui est très supérieur à celui de
livraison européen c'est pour ça que
plutôt que de parler de manière générale
même s'il y a d'autres choses à faire
que le réseau je vais y venir nous avons
besoin de dire que c'est sans doute là
où il faut mettre le plus
d'investissements les petites lignes et
puis après je reviendrai sur la question
des financements parce qu'en fait on
peut se dire qu'il faut plus d'argent
mais la question c'est comment on va
collectivement le mobiliser
un bon niveau et dans la durée parce que
je ne suis pas depuis très longtemps
cette fonction mais pour partager avec
vous avec une candeur assumée un
diagnostic ou un étonnement sur le
secteur des transports que le sénateur
Tabaro notamment connaissait depuis
longtemps
nous sommes dans un secteur qui parle
d'un tueur et celui du temps long
celui de projet
grande dimension on parle du réseau de
nouvelles lignes et où nous avons
beaucoup de mal à voir du pilotage de
long terme et des financements garantis
sur le long terme et d'ailleurs
globalement tout mode confondu me
semble-t-il même s'il y a des nuances à
avoir c'est dans les domaines où on a
réussi à créer une garantie de
financement sur le temps long qu'on a
les meilleurs résultats on peut avoir un
débat nous y reviendrons sur les
concessions autoroutières force est de
constater que indépendamment des
questions sur la répartition de la
valeur entre le constédant et les
concessionnaires entre le
concessionnaire et les conseils le
concédant et les concessionnaires pardon
nous avons un réseau qui est bien
entretenu là où le réseau routine
national a souffert de coûts d'accordéon
budgétaires soyons honnêtes
parce que nous n'avons pas de garantie
de financement pluriel
et nous le voyons dans le secteur de
l'aéroportuaire si nous avons les
infrastructures et reportuaires d'assez
bonne qualité c'est parce que nous avons
aussi des régulations pluriannuelles qui
permettent les investissements donc je
crois que cette question est essentielle
je fais un petit détour pardon je l'ai
dit à l'instant sur les petites lignes
parce que je pense que c'est très
important ça a été d'abord un engagement
pris donc il est toujours mieux de tenir
ses engagements par le premier ministre
Jean Castex il y a 8 protocoles qui ont
été signés entre l'État et les régions
il faut que chacun ils prennent sa part
les régions qui n'ont pas encore fait
peuvent changer d'avis je le souhaite
notamment la région Auvergne et
Rhône-Alpes nous avons un engagement qui
est important puisque ça couvre déjà 5,7
milliards d'euros d'investissement c'est
8 protocoles si je mets la totalité des
financements publics mobilisés et sa
porte au total sur 6300 km de ligne sur
un total de petites lignes comme on dit
identifier de 9000 km donc c'est un vrai
changement je pense que c'est important
et une partie d'entre elles je fais pas
le cas par cas une partie d'entre elles
il faut les inscrire en les transports
du quotidien parce que ça peut aussi
faciliter des liaisons qui aujourd'hui
ne se font pas
pour comment mobilise des financements
dans la durée je dis pas que c'est la
panacée mais je pense que c'est une
piste qu'on doit creuser qui est
d'ailleurs cohérente avec les
orientations de la l'homme ce sont des
sociétés de projet c'est pas un des
membres mangent je crois que c'est au
contraire une garantie de financement de
long terme on pourrait multiplier les
exemples et les critiques ou les débats
mais vous prenez l'Île-de-France nous
sommes aujourd'hui si nous n'avions pas
une société dédiée pour faire quatre
lignes de métro supplémentaires sans
doute nous n'aurions pas autant avancé
même s'il y a eu des difficultés je
pense à la Société du Grand Paris parce
qu'elle a une ressource affectée
garantie pour la durée
nous avons mis en place c'était
après les sœurs Elisabeth borne qu'il
avait initié le Parlement qu'il a voté
dans la Lomme pour certaines lignes à
grande vitesse qui sont en projet GPSO
LNPCA
lnpm nous avons des sociétés de projets
qui se mettent en place pour une
ressource locale affectée sans doute
d'ailleurs vous aurez en connaître des
EPLF pour ce qui concerne la société du
GPSO bien je crois que c'est une bonne
idée parce que ça garantit des
financements
ça crée de la valeur économique d'avoir
une ligne à grande vitesse notamment
pour les entreprises donc il n'est pas
totalement anormal que il y ait une
contribution et en même temps elle est
locale elle est ciblée là où la valeur
est le plus créé donc je crois que c'est
une illustration de ce que nous pouvons
faire donc nous avons un certain nombre
d'idées d'abord avant de recevoir le
rapport du coi je pense que le grand la
grande vertu du rapport du coi c'est que
de manière si on permettait ce mot
néanmoins laïque eucuménique et objectif
il met sur la table liste de priorités
nous mettrons la priorité sur le réseau
sur la base de ce rapport il y aura une
nouvelle programmation ce que j'ai dit
monsieur le Président c'est que je ne
sais pas vous dire aujourd'hui ce sont
les arbitrages décidées par la première
ministre dans les prochaines semaines à
l'issue sans doute de ce rapport est-ce
que cela prendra une forme législative
ou non je n'ai pas la réponse
aujourd'hui il faudra actualiser et
compléter notre programmation c'est tout
à fait clair sur j'ai noté votre
remarque amicale sur le oui merci pour
cette je rentrerai pas dans un
introspection trop psychanalytique mais
s'il y a ambiguïté je la lève
publiquement devant vous je n'ai pas
l'habitude de tenir des doubles discours
donc s'il y a eu malentendu je le
regrette j'ai dit 24 heures d'intervalle
aux gares et à la région de France que
je pensais du versement mobilité 1 il
faut le sécuriser je le maintien puisque
vous le savez qu'il y a des débats
récurrents pour savoir si il faut passer
à autre chose le baisser etc je crois
que ça n'est pas possible et pas le
moment
par ailleurs en général quand les
entreprises bénéficieraient si on avait
dans le scénario d'une baisse ou d'une
suppression soyons fous du versement
mobilité il faudrait quand même bien
financer le transport public qui
bénéficie à notre tissu économique et
que les employeurs prennent en charge
d'une autre façon en remboursant les
abonnements qui ne manqueraient pas
d'augmenter donc il y a de toute façon
une part un peu circulaire dans ce
raisonnement donc sécuriser le marché
mobilité je le maintiens je crois
l'avoir dit de manière
cohérente et permanente ce que j'ai dit
parce que j'ai une question en région de
France alors je peux pas essayer assez
clair c'est que moi je n'excluais pas un
débat
une discussion probablement d'ici la
prochaine loi de finance c'est un peu
rapidement sur le versement mobilité
dans son ensemble
à la question des seuils même si
personnellement je ne suis pas favorable
à ce qu'on les abaisse parce que je
crois qu'on a trouvé un équilibre et
qu'on réouvrirait un débat pour le coup
un peu philosophique sur le lancement
d'unité ça répartition est-ce que on
doit donner de la flexibilité aux
collectivités en fonction de leurs
efforts de transition écologique je n'ai
pas de réponse définitive aujourd'hui ça
sera un débat le moment venu
parlementaire mais moi je suis ouvert à
ce qu'on mène ce chantier de réflexion
je ne mets pas trop de pression sur le
COI parce que là pour le coup on déborde
un peu et je ne change pas trop votre
barque mais aussi dans la dans le
sillage de ce travail sur la
programmation de nos investissements
donc voilà pour être très clair je n'ai
pas annoncé le changement et aux
bénéfice des régions en l'espèce puisque
c'est la question que vous avez posée de
la répartition du versement mobilité
d'ailleurs vous n'aurez pas j'aurais
remarqué il n'y a pas de réforme
aujourd'hui dans le PLF du versement
militaire qui est prévu en revanche je
suis un grand défenseur de sa
sécurisation et pour vous donner mon
état d'esprit sur ce sujet
monsieur Jacquin ont imposé un certain
nombre de questions je vais essayer
d'être rapide les autoroutes pour être
très précis et là vous m'avez vous
manquerez pas de me rappeler mes
déclarations si elle me sortent de la
tête j'ai dit que il y a une formule qui
est prévue par les contrats j'ai pas
tout à fait dit qu'il fallait pas
respecter cette formule d'abord parce
que qu'on respecte pas le formule
contractuel on peut avoir un problème
j'ai dit simplement que
en fonction du niveau de l'inflation qui
sera connue au début du mois de novembre
puisque c'est une inflation qui va
d'octobre à octobre nous serions ce que
donne la formule et comme cet été
puisque j'essaie aussi d'être cohérent
j'avais déjà parlé de ce sujet cet été
en réponse à une question de presse
l'inflation qui était très élevée que
nous avons réussi un peu à modérer
aurait abouti point d'interrogation à
des hausse très élevés de 7 à 8% j'ai
cité à plusieurs reprises ce chiffre et
ce chiffre là me paraît je le dis en
termes de pouvoir d'achat un soutenable
si on est dans les eaux qui sont plus
modérés nous verrons que les sociétés
d'autoroute ce que nous faisons pour
l'année prochaine mais je n'ai pas
annoncé un nouveau cadre contractuel en
revanche j'ai une discussion je n'en dis
pas plus à ce stade mais avec les
sociétés autoroutes pour regarder tous
les leviers qui nous avons pour avoir
des hausses qui ne sont pas des hausses
insoutenables de 7 à 8%. je n'ai pas
visé à ma connaissance de chiffre cible
aujourd'hui je vais simplement dire que
nous ne pourrions pas avoir des hausses
aussi importantes que cela
pour être très clair
je vais être clair jusqu'au bout on est
dans un contexte d'inflation
j'ai pu lire de vérité des prix même
avec des mesures très puissantes qui
sont les coups de puissantes d'Europe
nous aurons des augmentations
énergétiques à la rentrée 15% là où
beaucoup de pays européens ont déjà subi
en 2022 des hausses qui sont parfois de
75 % ou plus de 100% dans certains pays
donc il faut trouver cet équilibre entre
réaliser que nous avons la situation
d'inflation
et en même temps prendre des mesures de
protection mais on le sait bien vous le
savez comme moi qui ont toujours un coup
à la fin quelqu'un paye donc il faut
trouver ce juste équilibre il n'est pas
encore défini pour les styles de route
je le partagerai évidemment avec vous
mais ce ne sera pas des hausses de 7 à
8%. sur la loi 3DS j'ai échangé avec le
prise en retenner à ce sujet je vous
rassure je ne sais pas si ça vous
rassure la collectivité et la région
Grand Est ce n'est pas la seule qui a un
certain nombre de questions et ou de
réserve nous avons reçu je suis en train
de faire analyser par les services du
ministère des Transports puisque la date
limite était le 30 septembre plusieurs
délibérations de département
principalement puisque c'était l'esprit
nous sommes en train de les analyser la
plupart sont assortis de questions de
réserve et le législateur dans sa grande
sagesse a prévu qu'il y ait trois mois
de discussion entre les services de
l'État et les collectivités concernées
pour apporter des éléments
techniques sur les coûts
d'infrastructures si des travaux sont
engagés financiers il y a une
compensation transvers qui est prévu par
la loi mais il y a parfois des travaux
très importants d'aménagement les
changeurs qui sont engagés donc il faut
aussi tenir compte de cela j'ai changé
avec plusieurs collectivités qui avaient
cette question l'Eure-et-Loir par
exemple et le grand est donc voilà nous
aurons cette phase de discussion
jusqu'au 31 décembre et terme de la loi
c'est au ministre des Transports qu'il
appartient de dire ce qui est transfert
ou pas et dans quelle condition avec
ensuite une phase de 2 ans de mise en
place mais donc je suis à votre
disposition vous avez évoqué des
questions de financement pour clarifier
cela la problématique régionale était un
peu spécifique puisque on parle que de
trois régions ma connaissance qui se
sont emparés de ce sujet
sur SNCF réseau je reviens pas en détail
pas vous faire aujourd'hui d'annonce sur
une trajectoire puisque c'est plus tard
que nous la définirons d'ici le début de
l'année prochaine mais pour 2023 je le
dis très sincèrement je le présente
plutôt comme un signal ou un coup de
pouce qui est un petit coup de pouce
mais qui donne la direction il y a le
contrat de performance et dans le budget
de la fuite ou 150 millions d'euros de
paiement était ajouté par rapport à la
trajectoire qui était prévue nous aurons
sur ces 150 millions une partie d'entre
eux ce sera voté par la fuite mais je
pense que ça sera je souhaite que ce
soit la principale action au sein de ces
150 millions pour donner un petit
financement supplémentaire à notre
réseau ferroviaire l'an prochain
c'est une fois et ce sont des montants
modestes mais complémentaires au 2,9 et
qui je le souhaite donne la direction
pour la suite de la programmation
sur la TVA 5,5%, je ferai une réponse
peut-être plus diplomatique c'est mon
ancienne origine ministériel
vous dire pour être très sincère moi je
crois que nos moyens financiers parle
d'argent public et la fin doivent être
avant tout consacrés c'est ça qui fait
le report modal et l'accessibilité ou
l'attractivité de nos transports publics
à l'offre plus qu'à la demande elle
offre à l'offre par un réseau de qualité
par des rames rénovés par des trains
nombreux et disponibles etc et là on a
déjà de quoi faire donc ce n'est pas
on rêve le plus absolu le ministre des
Transports qui cherchent toujours des
crédits je préfère qu'on ait des crédits
consacrés aux réseaux ça veut pas dire
je le dis aussi que notamment à court
terme notamment dans une période
d'inflation et de pouvoir d'achat qui
nous pose des difficultés on ne doit pas
réfléchir je n'ai pas encore de réponse
et la discussion parlementaire peut
l'éclairer à des mesures qui peuvent
encourager l'usage des transports
publics et je regarde
il peut pas être plus précis aujourd'hui
mais ce que font un certain nombre de
voisins européens nos amis allemands ont
mis en place une mesure le fameux billet
à 9 euros je vais être très honnête là
aussi je ne pense pas que ce soit la
meilleure mesure coût efficacité en
termes de report modal si c'est bien ça
qu'on cherche c'est une mesure
essentiellement sociale c'est important
mais dans un pays où le transport public
en général est beaucoup moins
subventionné qu'en France il faut quand
même boire de quoi l'on parle beaucoup
moins subventionné qu'en France mais je
ne m'en attribue pas le mérite ce sont
d'abord les collectivités qui portent
cet effort de subvention
le transport public c'est beaucoup plus
effondré en Allemagne pendant le covid
et beaucoup moins subventionné en
moyenne qu'en France et d'ailleurs ça a
été une mesure provisoire aujourd'hui
l'Allemagne est en train de réfléchir
j'en ai parlé avec mon homologue il y a
15 jours un dispositif de soutien en
transport public mais qui sera pas du
tout de même grandeur que les billets à
9 euros qui ont été mobilisés pour l'été
qui coûte 1 milliard d'euros par mois au
contribuable allemand donc ce serait un
ordre de grandeur à peu près similaire
en France voilà c'est pas dire et il y a
une expérience espagnole qui me paraît
mais on va regarder ce qu'elle donne
plus intéressant pour 4 mois expérimente
une très fort réduction voir la gratuité
des abonnements seulement des
abonnements de transport public
peut-être que ça va déclencher un usage
plus important en transport public
regardons-le moi je ne suis pas fermé à
des mesures sur la demande mais d'abord
elle coûte de l'argent donc il faut être
raisonnable et responsable et ensuite je
le dis de manière plus profonde et plus
structurée c'est vraiment l'offre de
transport sur laquelle on doit mettre le
paquet dans les années qui viennent
je vous dis quelques mots des
de la desserte
je reviens pas surtout historique que
vous connaissez mieux que moi il y a eu
des compensations entre guillemets des
vagues des offres TVR et TGV qui ne sont
pas tout à fait satisfaisantes je le
sais j'ai engagé un travail de
discussion fait pas de fausses promesses
aujourd'hui pour vous dire que tout ça
sera rétabli comme cela était avant mais
pour qu'on trouve des compléments à
l'offre présente je suis prêt à mener la
discussion avec vous pour que on trouve
les meilleurs moyens de dessert avec la
SNCF et avec vous-même et plusieurs élus
qui vont saisi de ce sujet
sur le versement mobilité je crois avoir
donné la philosophie
la question des taux peut faire partie
de cette discussion générale et de leur
différenciation
sur ce qui a été dit
le Revenge travel comme disent les
spécialistes du secteur en mauvais
français par un voyage de revanche qui
sonne un peu négatif peut-être mais oui
il y a eu une reprise très forte
effectivement une volonté de voyage très
forte cet été par rapport au commissaire
ça a expliqué dans l'aérien comme dans
le ferroviaire d'ailleurs une forte
hausse les prix
je pense était un peu exceptionnel aussi
dans ce contexte de reprise mais qui a
n'a pas empêché d'ailleurs la vente
massive de ses billets ni en train ni en
avion mais qui est un fait de l'été 2022
qui occasionné parfois les perturbations
et j'ai d'ailleurs demandé la Direction
générale de l'aviation civile en lien
avec les compagnies aériennes et les
infrastructures aéroportuaires d'avoir
un plan d'action très concret en termes
d'indemnisation en cas de retard
d'information des voyageurs etc pour
qu'on évite de vivre des scènes comme on
les a connu dans nos aéroports nos
grands aéroports cet été même si je le
dis aussi parce que c'est la
mobilisation du secteur qui l'a permis
la France a connu beaucoup moins de
perturbations que ce qu'on a vu à
l'aéroport d'Amsterdam à l'aéroport
disco à Londres où il y a eu des
annulations de vol par centaines même
par milliers au cours de l'été qu'on n'a
pas connu heureusement en France alors
pour décarbouler l'aviation puisque vous
avez cité ce sujet quels sont nos
leviers je crois d'abord à l'innovation
et à l'investissement et des choses sont
déjà faites je veux le souligner
deux leviers principalement
j'en ajouterai un troisième mais deux
principalement d'abord avoir des moteurs
plus économes c'est pas de la
science-fiction j'étais l'autre jour
dans le centre de recherche j'inauguré
le centre de recherche de
safran nous avons des générations de
moteurs qui d'une génération à l'autre
en l'espace d'une décennie peuvent
baisser leur consommation de carburant
de 20% à la consommation totale de la
viande de 20 %. les carburants propres
sont aussi évidemment une des solutions
majeures
et plus globalement les solutions
propres pour l'aviation avec des degrés
de maturité vous le savez mieux que moi
très différents sur l'hydrogène sur
l'électrique peut-être pour les petits
mais sans doute pas pour les gros avions
à court terme et donc les carburants bio
ou de synthèse peuvent être une son à
mon avis la priorité aujourd'hui pour
baisser avec la consommation des moteurs
la consommation générale c'est pour ça
qu'on a ce texte européen que j'évoquais
pour être le plus
propre possible si je puis dire et
l'Europe serait le premier espace au
monde à se doter de ces règles sur les
safs la France a d'ailleurs montré
l'exemple ce que nous avons déjà sont
plus basses mais des obligations
d'incorporation et nous sommes le seul
pays l'Union européenne aujourd'hui il y
a des compléments pour ça que j'évoquais
d'autres leviers vous avez parlé de
trajectoires notamment ce qu'on appelle
les descentes continues qui posent
d'autres questions sur la répartition
des nuisances sonores puisque le
principe a descendre continue si je suis
très simple c'est que vous avez moins de
personnes embêté par les nuisances de
l'avion au moment aux alentours des
aéroports mais elles sont plus
concentrées elle consomme moins sur le
plan environnemental mais elles sont
aussi plus concentrées sur un moins
nombreux à moins grand nombre de nos
concitoyens enfin il y a des effets de
répartition donc il faut les regarder au
cas par cas pour tous les aéroports
c'est ce que je suis en train de faire
sur Nantes par exemple avec plusieurs
élus sur la question des jets privés je
veux pas être trop long mais c'est
important vous avez raison de dire que
c'est pas une catégorie juridique
précise ce qu'on appelle parfois
moi-même dans le débat de jet privé ça
n'est pas dans la loi ou dans le
règlement on peut dire en revanche c'est
l'aviation privée ça en cette définir
qui a le même deux catégories
principales commerciales ou non
commercial non commercial c'est quand
vous possédez vous même mais personne
angète l'entreprise ou en particulier
c'est là que je crois qu'on peut faire
le plus d'efforts de modération voire
d'alignement de notre fiscalité puisque
en réalité il y a un avantage fiscal à
cette aviation là c'est assez difficile
à comprendre même par rapport à d'autres
usages vie privés comme l'aviation de
loisirs donc le jet privé comme on
l'entend dans le débat public et moins
taxé que l'aviation de loisirs c'est
quand même paradoxal et dans l'aviation
privée commerciale vous avez par exemple
du transfert sanitaire vous avez des
recours ponctuels d'une entreprise à un
moyen d'aviation qui peut être justifié
et donc là je crois qu'en effet il faut
bien cibler notre objectif c'est que il
y a un usage modéré jamais parlé
d'interdiction à l'usage modéré avec des
règles européennes qui seront discutées
d'ailleurs le 15 octobre entre les
ministres et les transports avec une
taxation équitable notamment de cette
aviation privée non commerciale
sur
je crois n'oubliez rien sur votre
expression sur les questions vous avez
posé madame madame Bonnefoy sur la RN 10
en particulier je vais pas être trop
long mais c'est important vous le savez
des études ont été engagées par mes
prédécesseurs elles ont abouti à
l'analyse que nous avons deux
difficultés si nous voulions réguler
mettre des interdictions des horaires ou
des régulations sur la route nationale
c'est que au total l'effet de report sur
l'autoroute serait sans doute
disent les études limitées et par
ailleurs nous avons surtout un problème
juridique parce que pour avoir une
interdiction il faut que nous puissions
avoir des raisons environnementales
extrêmement documentées parce que c'est
une restriction à la liberté de
circulation et donc j'ai mis beaucoup de
cas je suis resté sur beaucoup de cas
encore récemment par exemple en
nouvelle-aquitaine ou c'est très
difficile de prendre une telle mesure
sans risque juridique néanmoins moi je
suis ouvert à continuer ce travail et je
suis aussi ouvert à la transparence et
donc à partager avec vous le détail de
ces études pour qu'on puisse continuer
le travail pas au calendrier mais dans
les prochaines semaines avec vous je
prends cet engagement on va interroger
sur les transports scolaires je vais
être rapide parce que d'accord avec vous
je l'ai dit au garde lors d'un premier
réunion parce que comme l'a rappelé le
sénateur Tabaro il vaut mieux toujours
dire la même chose donc je l'ai dit au
garde en privé je le dis ici en public
je ne suis pas favorable à ce qu'on
revienne sur cette règle le gars vous
connaissez cette revendication de longue
date mais de bonne foi nous dit que il
peut y avoir des conditions
sécurisées de transport debout et donc
j'ai dit au garde pour être tout à fait
complet je ne crois pas trahir de grands
secrets que s'il voulait de nouveau
produire une étude scientifique sur
l'accidentologie et les risques je serai
prêt à la regarder mais que mon
sentiment très net c'est que il ne
fallait pas revenir là-dessus la
dernière fois que je crois il y avait un
débat au Parlement sur cette question
c'était au moment de l'homme et le
gouvernement par la voix à l'époque
d'Elisabeth borne avait été très clair
je suis tout aussi clair
sur les questions que vous avez posé
madame leiderac
sur les Jeux Olympiques vous avez raison
c'est un défi majeur pour donner un
chiffre c'est
la plus grande opération de transport en
Île-de-France ce n'est pas que
l'Île-de-France qui est concerné mais
principalement en temps de paix et c'est
800 000 personnes qui seront
transportées ou transportables
potentiellement chaque jour
entre les spectateurs et les délégués
athlètes et accrédités donc c'est un
effort massif qu'il faut faire avec un
travail énorme de coordination puisqu'il
y a plusieurs acteurs l'état une
responsabilité
IDFM pour la région Île-de-France en
particulier pour être très concret je
vais réunir je le ferai désormais toutes
les 6 semaines à partir du 12 octobre un
comité des mobilités qui mettra tous les
acteurs autour de la table nos grands
opérateurs RATP SNCF etc ADP pour les
aéroports les grands élus concernés
notamment évidemment la direction d'idfm
le directeur le délégué pardon
interministériologiques monsieur Cadot
le Kojo etc tous les acteurs seront
réunis à partir du 2 octobre toutes les
six semaines et on fera un point très
concret sur le plan de transport
les voies réservées les accès vélo le
parcours client aux usagers si je puis
dire en aéroport dans les transports
publics les infrastructures que nous
mettons en place pour les JO mais à
l'occasion des JO elles seront ouvertes
je pense à l'indicateur jouer au
carrefour Pleyel etc donc tout sera
passé en revue comme une réunion le
chantier très précise avec l'ensemble
des acteurs toutes les six semaines je
commence avec la mise des sports ce 12
octobre sur le dialogue interrégional
notamment avec la Normandie que vous
avez appelé de vos vœux il y a
différentes problématiques qui touche à
qui touche à l'offre de TER moi je suis
prêt à accompagner ce dialogue
interrénal il se trouve que un des bouts
de la chaîne j'en parlais ce matin même
avec la présidente Valérie Pécresse et
je suis prêt à le faciliter l'État n'a
qu'une part de la solution mais elle
facilité dans les semaines qui viennent
et dans le cadre de la négociation des
CPR vous m'avez interrogé aussi sur les
questions
de bruit
là aussi vous l'avez rappelé il y a un
arrêté qui sera pris dans les toutes
prochaines semaines pour mettre en place
des expérimentations de six mois sur un
panel existe de lignes existantes et
deux ans et demi sur tous les projets de
construction de modifications
significatives la phrase structure
ferroviaire le mieux pour avoir ses
prévus en effet par la l'homme une
analyse des pics de bruit et des
vibrations c'est d'avoir une analyse
scientifique partagée et donc c'est
arrêté en définira le cadre et sur les
bruits solidiens vous savez que les
travaux ont démarré et devraient aboutir
c'est aussi prévu par la l'homme courant
2023 je suis prêt aussi à en faire le
suivi sur les questions que vous avez
posées monsieur le secteur Fernique Lyon
Turin alors je me suis longuement
exprimé hier mais c'était à l'Assemblée
nationale sur la question de l'eau il y
a diverses questions il y a c'est un
fait
l'infrastructure sur sa section actuelle
transfrontalière qui est en construction
et dans des périmètres d'arrêter de
captage afin d'arrêter sur
l'organisation des captages le frais est
très régulièrement car il faut qu'il y
ait aucune ambiguïté aucune opacité sur
ce sujet n'aop pas identifié aujourd'hui
avec les autorités sanitaires de risque
sur les captages mais cette
préoccupation a été relayée à plusieurs
reprises par le député à marierne donc
moi je suis prêt à regarder de suivi
transparent régulier sur ce sujet il y a
un point sur lequel j'insiste c'est que
toutes les procédures puisqu'en doute a
parfois été exprimé y compris au titre
de la loi sur l'eau bien été respectée
au moment du lancement de ce projet de
l'octroi de la DUP il y a maintenant 15
ans et la réglementation loi sur l'eau a
été scrupuleusement suivi j'ai dit je ne
reprends pas mon compte au contraire
l'idée d'un sous-investissement
ferroviaire est très sincèrement je
pense qu'on peut avoir des débats et
qu'on partage tous l'idée que sur
beaucoup de segments il faut investir le
plus possible notamment sur le réseau je
n'y reviens pas mais vraiment on peut
pas dire que nous soyons dans un pays de
négligence du ferroviaire je crois que
ce serait pas juste et ce serait pas
juste en comparaison européenne aussi
donc existe vraiment sur le lion Turin
pour finir et revenir sur ce point il y
a un deuxième moment qui est très
important que la question des des
scénarios sur les accès je précise là
aussi les choses puisque j'ai tenu une
réunion j'ai voulu la faire rapidement
car il y avait beaucoup de demandes avec
les élus les collectivités financeurs
concernées à Lyon le 15 septembre
je n'ai l'État n'a pas choisi c'est pas
la démarche qui avait été suivie même
par mes prédécesseurs je suis leur
démarche de scénario nous n'avons pas
exprimé de l'opération préférentielles
vous avez dit le préfet a été à
l'initiative de discussion c'est
initiative de soluce de consultation
c'est l'État qui a demandé au préfet le
gouvernement mon prédécesseur préférée
de mener les consultations le préfet
maillot se l'a fait jusqu'à décembre
2021 et il n'y a pas de consensus parce
que notamment du côté de la Haute-Savoie
les expressions un peu différente mais
tout le monde convient que l'immense
majorité des collectivités ont dit
qu'elle préférait le scénario dit grand
gabarits c'est pas l'état qui l'a
exprimait nous n'avons vous avez trois
scénarios sur la table ce sont la
majorité des collectivités maintenant ce
que j'ai dit le 15 septembre pour être
tout à fait transparent là aussi c'est
que si tel était on peut pas changer de
pied si tel était l'option
préférentielle exprimée par une majorité
de collectivités par l'État d'en prendre
une autre mais en revanche est à l'état
de dire est-ce que tout le monde est
bien d'accord pour financer
parce que je le redis comme je l'ai dit
Assemblée nationale hier il faut qu'on
fasse de l'ambition ferroviaire il y a
une ambition budgétaire
on est souvent pour un projet ambitieux
jusqu'au moment où on en vient autour de
table et donc j'ai demandé au préfet le
signerai un nouveau mandat dans les
jours qui viennent pas de refaire la
concertation on l'a déjà fait mais de
faire une constatation sur ce volet
financier et de demander aux
collectivités concernées si chacun est
prêt à contribuer et à quelle hauteur
c'est une fois que cet éclairage
financier sera donné que l'État prendra
la décision sur le scénario des accès de
manière concertée et transparente là
aussi sur les financements européens je
sais qu'il y a une petite musique qui
s'étaient sur lesquelles même pour la
section transfrontalière on aurait pas
les financements européens c'est inexact
il tarde un peu à venir je m'en suis
expliqué que la commissaire européenne
ils sont essentiels au bouclage du
projet et sur
les scénarios d'accès il y aura des
financements européens il y a des règles
qui sont prévues quel que soit le
scénario qu'on retient ils peuvent pas
être définis aujourd'hui puisqu'on n'a
pas encore choisi le scénario mais
il n'y a pas je sais que ça a été
parfois dit il n'y a pas de risque si on
est passé la date de fin octobre ou de
fin novembre de perte des financements
européens il y a un appel à financement
qui est en cours et donc plus on va vite
plus on peut avoir des financements tôt
mais je crois pas que ça soit ça qui
doit déterminer le calendrier ce qui
doit déterminer dans les calendriers
c'est qu'il est urgence avoir de la
clarté c'est pas tellement l'urgence à
remplir la date administrative de telle
ou telle financement européen on
commencera à quoi qu'il arrive sur le
scénario des accès par des études et je
le rappelle ce sont les règles
européennes les études peuvent être
financées jusqu'à 50% par la Commission
européenne et ça ça ne disparaîtra pas
après le 30 octobre ou le 30 novembre
prochain donc voilà il y a c'est pas ça
qui doit dicter je crois notre démarche
qui doit dicter une démarche ça
nécessite d'y voir clair assez vite sur
les questions que vous avez posé
monsieur laelec donc
je vous remercie de l'invitation à un
jeu aussi de vos mots une ambition
nouvelle de développement je crois moi
être expliqué il faut que cette là aussi
cette ambition fait des ferroviaire
trouve son pendant budgétaire donc la
question c'est les modes de financement
beaucoup j'ai donné quelques pistes
et madame la sénatrice Saint-Pée sur le
sur le en même temps que vous avez
évoqué grande ligne petite ligne petite
ligne à grande vitesse je vais pas vous
dire le contraire de ce que j'ai dit
précédemment il faut avoir des priorités
quand les priorités c'est toujours
douloureux parce que ça veut dire qu'il
y a des choses qui passent avant
d'autres moi j'assume cette priorité
réseau et transport du quotidien je
pense qu'elles sont d'abord relativement
larges et ça ne veut pas dire plus de
LGV par exemple mais ça veut dire que en
effet dans un pays où nous avons déjà
beaucoup développé la grande vitesse où
je pense que c'est un atout économique
aussi mais je pense pas du tout qu'il
fallait renier ce choix collectif la
grande vitesse doit être financée sans
doute différemment et je ne reviens pas
sur la question les sociétés de projet
mais je pense que c'est aujourd'hui
pertinent pour de nouvelles lignes à
grande vitesse se focaliser sur ces
modes de financement et que les
ressources collectives payées par le
contribuable national soit plutôt
affecté à des domaines dans lesquels il
y a besoin d'un efforts national
renforcés notamment le réseau donc je
pense que c'est comme ça qu'en priorise
et pour le reste je le reverrai encore
aux travaux du coi mais non pas pour non
pas voilà non pas pour me dégager de ses
choix parce que je n'ai donné quand même
quelques pistes monsieur sénateur madame
la sénatrice mais parce que je pense que
ça donnera quand même non mais les
priorités je les ai données je paye
revenir mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y
aura pas qu'il y a pas le reste j'ai dit
que d'ailleurs les petites lignes les
protocoles sont engagées les crédits
sont mobilisés au sein de la fixe j'ai
pas parlé du fret j'ai pas parlé du
train de nuit il y a aussi des
engagements supplémentaires qui ont été
pris par notamment Jean Castex lorsqu'il
était Premier ministre nous tiendront
aussi ses engagements et notamment sur
les trains de nuit mais peut-être qu'on
y reviendra dans la suite de l'échange
et puis monsieur le sénateur je crois
avoir répondu au point que vous aviez
soulevé sur le lion Turin et sur les
financements européens
merci
Monsieur marchand madame privil monsieur
gilet monsieur gold
merci monsieur le Président m'excusant
auprès de monsieur le ministre mais je
ne pourrai prendre ce temps de sa
réponse devant partir pour un autre
engagement monsieur le ministre moi
aussi je vais vous parler aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympique puisque notre
pays va accueillir des événements
sportifs d'envergure dès lundi prochain
avec la Coupe du monde de rugby je ne
vous parlerai pas de la canicule mais au
printemps dernier les incidents de la
finale de la Ligue des Champions pour
lesquels la responsabilité des
Transporteurs a été écarté on néanmoins
mis en évidence la complexité pour les
opérateurs suite à des mouvements de
grève déclenchés
suite à au moyen de préavis limité
dormant on sait qu'existe également la
technique dite de la greffe perlée les
textes relatifs assez pratiques sont
interprétés différemment par les
organisations syndicales et les
directions générales aussi il ne
faudrait-il pas éclaircir la situation
rapidement sur ces sujets par ailleurs
les opérateurs sont demandeurs d'un
allongement du délai de déclaration pour
le passé de 48 heures à 72 heures et
passer celui du changement de date de 24
heures à 48 heures de manière à pouvoir
informer les usagers le plus en amont
possible n'est-il pas donc important de
se saisir de ces sujets rapidement dans
l'intérêt des usagers du quotidien bien
évidemment et aussi de celui de ce de
celles et ceux qui comptent sur les
transports en commun lors de leur visite
en France merci
madame Préville merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre alors
tout d'abord je vais vous évoquer un une
petite mésaventure d'hier matin donc je
prends l'avion j'ai pas d'autre
possibilité le train c'est beaucoup trop
long quand je viens de chez moi donc et
là il y avait pas de place à Brive donc
je vais à Aurillac je pars le vol
l'avion décolle nous volons pendant plus
d'une heure et arriver presque à Orly on
nous dit qu'on ne peut pas atterrir à
cause du brouillard et donc nous faisons
route arrière pour se reposer à Aurillac
deux heures après donc le bilan carbone
voilà et et voilà donc je ne savais pas
que c'était possible ça qu'on fasse
volle arrière et qu'on se repose deux
heures après enfin bref voilà donc il
arrive des trucs incroyables voilà
donc ça interroge quand même donc voilà
c'est pour le l'évoquer parce que
j'avais jamais vécu quelque chose comme
ça alors je vais faire le grand écart
maintenant parce que je vais parler vélo
et puisque vous nous avez dit que la
priorité c'était les mobilités du
quotidien effectivement le vélo et est
un levier extrêmement important à une
potentialité
phénoménale de développement quand on
sait que 60% des trajets
domicile-travail sont inférieurs à 5 km
et sont effectués en voiture le vélo
assistance électrique connaît un grand
succès il permet également de faire des
trajets de plusieurs kilomètres même
dans mon département qui est très
vallonné les vélos sont donc en forte
progression il y a une augmentation de
30% je pense ces derniers temps à tel
point qu'il y a des ruptures lorsqu'on
veut en acquérir un vous avez lancé des
programmes à vélo et quand j'ai regardé
de plus près bon ça consiste à des
appels à candidature sur des col
activités pour des co-financement
d'études expérimentation de campagne de
com et de création de postes de chargées
de mission et là je me dis
que je trouve qu'il y a un problème
parce que si on veut maintenant alors
que la chose est déjà bien lancée que
cela se développe beaucoup le
déplacement à vélo il faut absolument
pour que les gens puissent se déplacer
en toute sécurité avoir des pistes
cyclables dignes de ce nom et non pas
seulement une ligne blanche à quelques
centimètres du bord pris sur la chaussée
telle qu'elle était avant mais c'est
vrai que dans des villes dans des
départements on peut pas tellement faire
autrement alors est-ce que vous avez
pensé à faire un grand plan parce que là
un choc de l'offre il serait là un grand
plan de développement de vélo route je
sais pas comment on pourrait les appeler
comme il existe en Hollande c'est à dire
des petites routes cyclables qui sont en
dehors ils sont pas le long des routes
habituelles
ou comme en Allemagne où il y a vraiment
un espace qui sépare la route pour les
voitures et celle pour les vélos à
minima parce que nous n'avons pas ça en
France et dans mon département où il y a
un grand réseau ou des beaucoup de
personnes ont acquis des vélos
électriques parce que le département a
donné en plus des aides à l'acquisition
j'entends beaucoup que les uns et les
autres disent mais finalement j'ai pas
le faire c'est beaucoup trop dangereux
donc je pense que et après je comprends
bien c'est ces appels à candidature
c'est bien mais ça va concerner un
territoire et là on a besoin si on veut
bouger d'une ville à l'autre si on veut
à partir en vacances si on veut on est
toujours en fait à la frontière d'un
canton d'un département d'une communauté
de communes et donc si ça concerne qu'un
petit territoire ça va pas il faudrait
que un choix national très choc de
l'offre il faudrait qu'on soit partout
en possibilité d'aller d'une ville à une
autre
à vélo voilà donc c'est ce que je vous
demande voilà si vous avez envisagé ça
et là vraiment ce serait au delà de
proposer vraiment et en plus je pense
que ce sera un budget un minimum les
pistes comme ça c'est pas comme les
routes je pense que c'est quand même
nettement moins cher que de faire une
route ou roule des camions et des
voitures et au-delà de ça ce sera un
message à mon avis très fort pour faire
comprendre à tout le monde qu'on doit
changer
ce cette proposition et cette offre
possible et je pense que les Français
sont prêts à se déplacer davantage en
vélo très rapidement sur le pôle parce
que je suis donc département du Lot et
pour vous interpeller parce qu'on m'a
dit que c'était auprès de vous qu'il
fallait le faire et pas à la SNCF les
desserts du Lot sont
moins importantes sur la ligne POLT la
plupart des des trains maintenant
une grande partie s'arrête à Brive mais
nous le département du Lot on est juste
en dessous donc on a moins de
possibilités donc il faut quand même
regarder ça de près et puis bien
évidemment sur les petites lignes ma
commune est sur la ligne brivoriac donc
je vais pas redire mais voilà mes
collègues ont déjà parlé pour ces trains
du quotidien et après une dernière chose
dans mon département des citoyens ont
créé une société coopérative qui est
baptisée rail Coop qui réunit quand même
13000 sociétaires c'est des citoyens des
particuliers des collectivités avec pour
objectif de développer des services
ferroviaires fret et voyageurs dans le
cadre de service librement organisés et
en complémentarité des services
existants c'est-à-dire sur des services
que n'offrent plus la SNCF
cette coopérative est déjà rouler des
premiers temps de fret en Occitanie et
envisage de lancer une première ligne
voyageur entre Bordeaux et Lyon
peut-être que vous en avez entendu
parler sous réserve de la finance de la
finalisation sont autour de table
financier compte tenues des priorités du
gouvernement en matière ferroviaire quel
regard portez-vous sur cette initiative
citoyenne merci merci Monsieur gilet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la quadrature du cercle ou
l'équation impossible il faudrait donc
100 milliards d'euros pour mener à bien
tous les chantiers ferroviaires
rénovation du réseau transport du
quotidien petite ligne moyenne
renouvellement du matériel nous en
sommes loin il faudra donc il faudrait
donc faire des priorités et j'ai entendu
de votre part une une inflexion
intéressante
concernant une question précédente d'une
de mes collègues et je vais y revenir à
ce titre le projet GPSO interroge sur
ses incertitudes financières et son
caractère prioritaire tout d'abord le
montant affiché de 14 milliards d'euros
l'État s'est engagé à financer 40%. mais
aujourd'hui il ne mettrait que 4
milliards sur la table le ministre
Djebari avait précisé que ce n'était que
sur la ligne Bordeaux - Toulouse quid de
Bordeaux Dax
pour atteindre les fameux 40% allez-vous
financer les 1,6 milliards
supplémentaires
l'impossibilité de franchir l'Espagne
semble faire barrage au financement
européen et vous avez été interrogé à
l'Assemblée nationale sur ce sujet ce
financement vous le savez il est très
attendu à hauteur minimale de 20%. si
jamais la commission pour l'instant
estime que ce dossier n'est pas
prioritaire allez vous compenser cette
somme donc s'il y a un refus européen
allez-vous dans ce cas priorisez
Bordeaux Toulouse au détriment de
Bordeaux Dax en finançant néanmoins le
tronc commun puisqu'il y a un tronc
commun vous savez Bordeaux Toulouse et
ensuite Bordeaux Dax enfin quand le
président de la République a signé
l'ordonnance créant la société de projet
pour le financement de GPSO le Conseil
d'État en toute logique avait été saisis
pour avis
au cours d'une audition enregistrée au
Sénat le ministre Djebari c'était engagé
à publier et rendre public donc l'avis
du Conseil d'État ce qui n'est toujours
pas le cas à ce jour allez vous
respecter cet engagement je vous
remercie
[Musique]
je pense pas qu'il soit nécessaire de
vous refaire un état des lieux des
dysfonctionnements de la ligne intersité
Paris Clermont vous connaissez bien les
problèmes récurrents auxquels les
usagers doivent faire face qui vous ont
été rappelés lors de votre récente
visite à Clermont merci d'ailleurs pour
cette visite
néanmoins la confirmation d'un élément
qui était laissé sous le tapis à savoir
l'avis d'autorité environnementale ne
devrait pas accélérer le calendrier
prévu pour une amélioration tant
attendue des conditions de voyage
deuxième point les problèmes que nous
connaissons sont communs à de nombreux
territoires et pour appréhender les
attentes du ferroviaire dans un contexte
de changement climatique profond je
reste persuadé qu'il faille les inscrire
dans une démarche beaucoup plus
ambitieuse et prospective avec une loi
de programmation plus réelle du
ferroviaire ambition reprise par
d'autres intervenants avant moi et que
vous avez abordé dans vos réponses à la
première salle de question et puis le
troisième point
concerne plutôt les transports du
quotidien les innovations fleurissent
dans le champ des transports collectifs
avec par exemple les trains trames les
trains lé les trains bus ou encore les
trains mixtes qui transportent en même
temps voyageurs et fret les territoires
et notamment les moins peuplés sont en
recherche de solution pour réduire la
place de la voiture individuelle et sont
prêtes à investir
dans des dispositifs innovants à
condition d'être accompagnées et soutenu
par l'État moi j'aimerais tout
simplement savoir quelle place vous
accordez à l'innovation à
l'expérimentation pour mieux adapter le
ferroviaire aux besoins de nos
territoires et je voudrais aussi
m'excuser parce que je serais attentif à
votre réponse mais la réponse qu'en fait
dans le compte rendu parce que je suis
obligé de vous quitter pour une réunion
que je peux pas rater à l'extérieur
merci Monsieur Chevrollier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voulais évoquer aussi
l'enjeu de l'électrification du parc
automobile pour améliorer entre autres
la qualité de l'air dans les
agglomérations vous interrogez sur la
nécessité du soutien pour les nos
concitoyens les plus modestes enfin j'ai
compris qu'il fallait attendre un peu
pour avoir les les modalités du leasing
social qui est très attendu par par nos
concitoyens et ce leasing il est un peu
combiné aussi avec l'entrée en vigueur
des des aides et feu est-ce que
aujourd'hui vous pouvez nous nous dire
très officiellement si les délais
d'entrée en vigueur des idées feux
pourront être tenus ma deuxième question
Franco a au point 2 que vous avez ou
trois que vous avez évoqué sur la
nécessité bien sûr de décarboner le
secteur des transports et je voudrais
dans le cadre de ce débat aborder
l'impact de la flambée du prix du gaz
sur le bio GNV dont le prix à la pompe a
doublé en un an dépassant désormais de
30% le prix du gazole et donc cette
situation pénalise fortement les
entreprises et les collectivités locales
qui se sont engagés dans la conversion
de leur flotte de véhicules vers le
bureau GNV qui est plus vertueux sur le
plan environnemental donc quels sont les
mécanismes
envisagés par le gouvernement afin de
garder pour le bio GNV un prix
compétitif et extrêmement important pour
soutenir
la filière dans nos territoires ruraux
en particulier qui sont engagés dans la
transition énergétique et qui
soutiennent les projets de méthanisation
ce qui est ce qui est le cas dans mon
département de la Mayenne et enfin
dernier point à l'occasion d'une visite
chez un transporteur routier de mon
département on m'a interrogé sur
l'autorisation d'avoir une double
remorque sur certains sur certaines
voies routières c'est un sujet qui est
pas nouveau mais dans le contexte où il
faut limiter le nombre de camions qui
permettrait de limiter les émissions et
donc limiter l'impact environnemental du
secteur est-ce que sur cette question là
en particulier des évolutions sont
envisageables en tout cas elles sont
attendues par certains professionnels du
secteur je vous remercie
merci chers collègues madame filleul
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je souhaitais vous interroger
sur la question du report modal et plus
particulièrement de la question de
l'articulation entre fleuve route et
fleuves rail une question très sensible
dans les ports en particulier mais pas
seulement je voulais souligner que dans
les discours tout le monde s'accorde
toujours pour dire qu'il faut faire un
effort maximum et que les réchauffements
climatique nous impose d'avancer et dans
les faits je mesure qu'il y a peu de
traduction de ces volontés politiques et
je ne prendrai comme exemple que celui
du canal senor dans ma région donc vous
savez un projet très engageant depuis
des décennies 5 milliards d'euros des
collectivités à l'oeuvre et des
ambitions écologiques importantes bien
sûr or le projet initial comport les
quatre plateformes trimodale et au bout
au bout du compte pour des raisons
financières seulement deux plateformes
trimodal seront réalisés et ainsi
finalement on renoncera encore une fois
à utiliser toutes les potentialités de
ce formidable projet donc je voulais je
sais que l'heure est peu propice mais
j'aurais bien aimé connaître votre
vision du report modal et quels moyens
réellement vous pensiez mettre en œuvre
pour le favoriser
merci Monsieur devinez merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais le temps s'est
écoulé mais je sois heureux de venir sur
sur Lyon Turin qui est quand même
précisé que c'est une très mauvaise
appellation Lyon Turin puisque c'est
tout compte fait le tronçon qui marche
manque pour rejoindre le Portugal pour
permettre de rejoindre le Portugal au
reste de l'Europe et il me semble que
dans les dernières évolutions il y a
rééquilibrage en faveur du fait du fret
qui sur le plan de l'agglomération
lyonnaise me paraît intéressant je
voudrais aussi sur les accès j'ai essayé
d'y comprendre votre réponse mais il me
semble que si on tarde que tu es
français à faire les accès ou à répondre
aux accès pour rejoindre le tunnel c'est
le prendre le risque de ne pas
bénéficier de 50% du financement de
l'Europe ça veut pas dire qu'il y aura
pas de financement mais aujourd'hui on
pourrait bénéficier de 50% de
financement dans ces projets je voudrais
rajouter moi le CEFAL où on en est sur
le contournement Est de l'agglomération
lyonnaise et attirer votre attention sur
le fait que y compris le Céphale comme
Vion Turin tout ça va être et envisager
d'être progressé sur la liaison qui fait
les Alpes vallées du Rhône pour passer
en rive droite du Rhône et la SNCF fait
savoir que ces réseaux sont déjà saturés
donc pourquoi on envisage pas à partir
de cette Exupéry de prolonger tout ça le
long de la ligne de TGV à grande vitesse
moi j'avais deux autres questions sur
les aérien à Toulouse une quarantaine de
pays ont promu un objectif loi de 0
émissions d'ici 2050 ça passe par des
carburants des nouveaux carburants
est-ce qu'ils vont être disponibles
est-ce qu'ils seront en quantité
suffisante derrière tout ça il y a un
pari technologique qui est pris avec ces
nouveaux carburants est-ce que ces
technologies
[Musique]
la liberté d'aller devenir et en
précisant c'est comme si l'on
interdisait la voiture quand une
alternative en transport en commun
existe bon en ce moment sur la métropole
de Lyon je participe à la mise en place
de la zone affaiblissement
pour cette métropole j'ai un peu le
sentiment que je suis en train
d'appliquer ce que
me reprochait la ministre wargot quelque
part c'est indirectement en tous les cas
on va encourager fortement les gens à
laisser leur voiture à utiliser les
transports en commun moi ma question
j'ai bien entendu les précisions que
vous avez amené tout à l'heure sur ces
vols privés les différences mais c'est
qu'est-ce que vous comptez faire pour au
niveau de votre gouvernement pour
réglementer ses votes et plus
généralement pour que la contribution de
toutes les Françaises et les françaises
soient effectifs dans les efforts de
réduction de coco 2 et d'économie
d'énergie voilà pas porter l'école
rouler uniquement pour faire donner des
vols privés
monsieur Genet merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre merci de
votre leçon d'anatomie des transports à
laquelle vous êtes livrés si vous me
permettez de filer la métaphore je vous
crée tout d'abord les poumons le secteur
des transports est l'une des causes de
pollution atmosphérique majeure qui
constitue un risque environnemental pour
la santé en Europe or au niveau de
l'Union européenne on annonce dans les
prochains jours des propositions de
modification des directives européennes
sur la qualité de l'air or il me semble
que de nouvelles recommandations de
l'OMS suggèrent désormais des
concentrations maximales
considérablement plus faibles pour les
principaux polluants est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un mot sur la position
de la France en la matière sur cette
reconnaissance des recommandations de
l'OMS et sur les conséquences que ça
peut avoir dans le domaine du transport
et puis pour revenir au sujet marquant
qu'on a tous évoqué à savoir la colonne
vertébrale
modernisation du réseau Ferrovial vous
avez présenté comme la colonne
vertébrale des mobilités je ne
reviendrai pas sur la sciatique ou la
véritable hernie discale que connaît le
Clermont-Ferrand Lyon et qui peut
intéresser des territoires connexes
comme celui de la Saône-et-Loire en
particulier l'ouest de la Saône-et-Loire
je vous parlerai plutôt de la fêlure
d'une des côtes de cette colonne
vertébrale la ligne TER par elmoniale
Lyon entre la Saône-et-Loire et le Rhône
qui souffrent d'un potentiel inexploité
en raison d'aménagement insuffisant je
crois que c'est une belle illustration
de ce que vous nous avez dit sur ces
petites lignes du quotidien l'absence de
zone d'évitement et de permanence au
poste d'aiguillages limite en effet la
circulation à seulement 4 allers-retours
par jour pour gagner la métropole
lyonnaise et ça insatisfait bien sûr les
usagers qui souhaitent privilégier les
transports en commun vous me permettrez
donc de former le vœu que sur cette
ligne monsieur le ministre on ne reste
pas à
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
ministre ils sont en bourre tant les
questions de transport sont au cœur des
problématiques de notre commission parce
ce qui me concerne j'ai deux points deux
points à aborder le premier c'est le
faire outrage donc c'est avec le faire
routage consiste à positionner des semis
remorques sur des camions et ça
constitue bien évidemment une réponse
efficace à la décarbonation des transit
du transport routier néanmoins ce mode
reste marginal des initiatives ont été
prises notamment sur les axes Calais qui
relie Calais à l'Italie qui allait à
l'Espagne de même pour le chien
bourgeois que je suis l'armateur
Britanny ferries porte un projet entre
le port transmence de Cherbourg et la
gare de Bayonne Mougères dans l'objectif
c'est de transformer donc 20000
remorques par an donc un accord cadre
d'ailleurs été signé avec la SNCF
néanmoins je doute personnellement de la
capacité comme toujours de la SNCF à
réaliser les aménagements ferroviaires
en temps et en heure donc j'ai double
question la première c'est à savoir si
le gouvernement va lancer de nouveaux
appels d'offres qui vont ou d'appel à
projet pour le développement de nouveaux
services d'autoroute ferroviaire et puis
aussi de quels moyens de contrôle on
peut se doter pour voir si les
engagements qui ont été pris par les
différents partenaires sont respectés et
puis vous m'excuserez
puisque on fait on balaye un peu l'Atlas
des chemins de fer je vais parler de
savoir si on peut avoir des nouvelles de
la ligne nouvelle Paris Normandie ça
fait plus de 20 ans qu'on en parle 10
ans que que la première enquête publique
a été menée vous savez qu'il faut pour
relier pour faire les 310 km entre
Cherbourg et Paris il faut comment dire
entre 3h15 et 3h45 donc le Sénat produit
des rapports volumineux donc on a le
temps de les lire mais néanmoins donc la
qualité du service laissa désirer et je
voulais savoir si au-delà de ce qu'on a
appelé le saute-mouton et le projet hall
qui permet de déconnecter le trafic
banlieue parisien du trafic grande ligne
il y a des avancées significatives sur
ce projet à dans les années qui viennent
merci Monsieur anglar Merci monsieur le
Président alors j'avais juste une
question monsieur le ministre remercie
qui concerne le chantier de la RN de 88
la N88 c'est l'axe Toulouse Lyon et les
40 km qui restent à faire n'est-ce pas
entre Rodez et Séverac-le-Château il y a
eu des discussions avec votre
prédécesseur et le Premier ministre sur
ce sujet je voulais savoir si vous aviez
toujours les cartons ce chantier pour
qu'on puisse enfin le réaliser je
remercie
merci chers collègues monsieur Guéret
oui monsieur le ministre lors de son
audition devant notre commission le 14
septembre dernier le président de la
SNCF Jean-Pierre ferrandoux a confirmé
le véritable challenge que représente
l'hydrogène vert pour le train à
condition que nous soyons en mesure d'en
produire massivement un cours
raisonnable je le cite et le distribuer
partout sur le territoire il a évoqué
être confiant pour relever ce challenge
et envisage une possible utilisation de
cette source d'énergie verte d'ici 10 à
15 ans c'est-à-dire une période assez
courte en remplacement du diesel dès
lors dans cette hypothèse comment vont
se synchroniser les investissements
engagés pour développer l'hydrogène vert
avec ceux déjà engagés dans le cadre de
contrat de plan fléchés sur des lignes
actuellement ferroviaires diesel à cet
égard et plus particulièrement pour un
territoire qui m'est cher quel choix
sera opéré concernant deux lignes du
quotidien importante en Eure-et-Loir que
sont des liaisons chaque court talent
est toujours Châteaudun Paris vous
comprenez que mon inquiétude c'est que
on ne dise pas dans 10 ans que
s'agissant de lignes sur lesquelles on
aura fait de remarquable investissements
c'est le cas actuellement le passage du
diesel à l'hydrogène n'a pas été
suffisamment préparé et qu'à nouveau à
ce moment-là tout un débat soit lancé
sur leur sur la pérennisation de ces
lignes merci monsieur le ministre
merci pour conclure monsieur point trop
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre tout à l'heure vous avez donc
une question d'actualité sur le la ligne
Paris ne vers Clermont qui est en
mauvais état on le sait
certains voyageurs sont restés encore 17
heures bloqués dans le train il y a pas
très longtemps moi je vais vous parler
de la ligne Paul
puisque vous savez que la rénovation de
cette ligne ferroviaire Paris Orléans
Limoges Toulouse et il était prévu sur
cette ligne de gros travaux de pour une
fin de chantier 2025 2026
on espérait avec votre arrivée une
accélération de ce projet et
malheureusement puisque vous êtes allé à
Clermont-Ferrand le 15 septembre dernier
et vous avez annoncé donc un retard de
livraison des 16 nouvelles rames
intercitées qui étaient prévues sur
cette ligne pault alors vous expliquer
que c'est la crise sanitaire du covid 19
mais nous souhaiterions savoir
concrètement
comment vous voyez les choses sur
l'avenir parce que vous savez qu'en 2024
les Jeux Olympiques
vont se dérouler dans notre pays à
Châteauroux nous aurons les épreuves de
tir et ça serait quand même bien qu'on
puisse obtenir des des rames
dignes de snow pour accueillir tous les
sportifs du monde
ça c'était ma première question
apparemment la région
Aquitaine
n'est pas favorable au financement il y
a des négociations qui sont en cours
je voulais savoir aussi là où on en
était le deuxième sujet c'est le
bourgement du son puisque le bourgement
du son n'est plus dans le giron de la
région Centre-Val de Loire et c'est une
ligne d'équilibre pour nos territoires
ruraux on en parle depuis déjà très
longtemps il y a des travaux de prévu
mais on voit pas la le départ de ces
travaux je voulais savoir si vous aviez
des des éléments à nous fournir et
compte tenu bon de cette volonté de
rénover l'existant et de faire en sorte
qu'on puisse ensuite avoir on l'espère
une ligne grande vitesse digne de Snow
avec la ligne pop qui permettra de
résoudre tout un tas de problèmes que
nous avons entre Paris Orléans Clermont
et Lyon et qui permettra aussi de faire
la continuité avec le naturel est-ce
qu'on peut avoir un espoir de voir un
jour ce projet se réaliser puisque il y
a une tierce expertise qui est en cours
et le préfet de coordonnateur de la
région
aura donc devrait donner un certain
nombre d'éléments en 2023 donc à la
suite de cette tiers expertise est-ce
que vous pensez que on pourra espérer
encore une fois ce rêve se réaliser
monsieur le ministre
je vous donne la parole le menu est
copié monsieur le président
essayez de d'être le plus
complet possible et pas trop trop long
sur la question que vous m'avez monsieur
marchand sur les Jeux Olympiques et les
questions sociales
on aura
avoir une discussion et sociale avec
avec nos opérateurs pour être très clair
à partir de sans doute la fin de l'année
on peut pas en effet imaginer que il y a
pas une mobilisation générale et une
responsabilité générale pour un
événement de cette nature est-ce qu'il
faut faire évoluer notre dispositif
législatif non je suis pas sûr
et c'est une question qui devra se
discuter avec ce que vous marchons à
citer les propositions et issues de
l'UTP notamment nous aurons bientôt une
nouvelle présidente de la RATP puisque
ce sera l'un des principaux opérateurs
concernés nous aurons cette discussion
pouvoir les engagements qui peuvent être
pris les discussions sociales qu'on doit
avoir en amont de jeux olympiques en
sentiment à ce stade c'est que avoir un
nouvel équilibre législatif n'est pas
n'est pas requis et n'est pas
indispensable mais je pense qu'il faut
on est tous un sentiment et y compris
évidemment
l'ensemble des agents de l'engagement et
de responsabilité dans ces jeux
olympiques
sur les questions que vous avez posées
madame prévil alors je suis confus pour
cette mauvaise expérience aérienne
j'avoue que je n'avais pas de
connaissances à titre personnel d'une
expérience de cette nature un
détournement d'un aéroport à l'autre ça
peut arriver pour des questions mais je
sais c'est une un retour en arrière ça
je n'avais pas donc je suis confus
j'espère que ça ne se l'exemple se
multiplieront pas je pense que c'est
assez exceptionnel sur la question du
vélo vous avez souligné à juste titre
la nécessité de faire plus en termes
d'infrastructure et j'allais dire même
aussi en terme de de sécurité quand on
fait les études dans tous les pays les
plus avancés on sait que ce sont les
deux facteurs les plus importants de
l'usage du vélo il faut un site protéger
et il faut un endroit protégé sécurisé
pour laisser son vélo un point d'accès
stationnement sécurisé en gare ou à côté
de chez soi et donc c'est justement là
dessus qu'on veut mettre l'accent dans
le nouvel appel à projet ou à
manifestation d'intérêt que la première
ministre a annoncé en renforçant le fond
mobilité active de 250 millions d'euros
pour l'année 2023 et elle a précisé 200
millions d'euros seront dédiés aux
infrastructures prioritairement 50
millions d'euros aux questions de
stationnement sécurisées et nous sommes
en train d'en définir les paramètres il
y aura un comité interministériel du
vélo pour la première fois sous la
présidence la première mise d'ici la fin
de l'année et un tous les six mois et
c'est là que nous accepterons sans que
les paramètres de ce cette nouvelle
contractualisation des collectivités
avec l'idée de justement privilégier ce
que ça fait déjà quatre ans qu'on
déploie ses aides d'État complémentaires
à celle des collectivités pour le vélo
les collectivités qui ont moins d'avance
au moins de ressources pour développer
des infrastructures sécurisées de très
grandes villes ont parfois soit pris de
l'avance soit plus de moyens tout
simplement justement pour développer ces
infrastructures on le voit dans
certaines grandes villes que nous
connaissons bien elle progresse
ces sites propres pour les vélos mais
pour les collectivités plus petites des
zones plus rurales c'est moins naturel
c'est plus coûteux et donc il faut qu'on
concentre les moyens sur cette idée je
veux quand même le donner un chiffre
parce qu'il est important nous avions en
France en 2017 40000 pistes 40000 km
parlons de pistes Lab et de voie verte
on en est à
50055800 km donc c'est quand même un
effort très important une augmentation
de 40%, et il faut qu'on continue vous
avez parlé aussi si je me trompe pas de
vélo route c'est très important en
matière de cyclotourisme en particulier
on en est à de mémoire à 19000 km de
vélo route on doit approcher maintenant
les 20000 c'est aussi un des points sur
avec elle on veut c'est un partenariat
collectivité et terme mais mobiliser des
financements c'est une des conditions
pour atteindre l'objectif qu'on s'est
fixé pour 2030 qui est de faire de la
France la première nation du
cyclotourisme du premier pays
touristique mondial on doit être en
termes d'infrastructure et d'accueil la
première nation du cyclotourisme vous
avez parlé de plusieurs sujets si je ne
me trompe pas la desserte du lot en
particulier ça je vous propose de faire
un point particulier vous avez évoqué je
crois Paris Aurillac aussi si je me
trompe brivoriac pardon
en petite dans les petites lignes ça je
vous ferai un point sur le calendrier
pour être plus précis et sur les
initiatives qu'on peut mobiliser
complémentaires de
d'opérateurs ou de fournisseurs qui
peuvent être des compléments les
alternatives à l'opérateur historique
up en particulier c'est un modèle en
effet innovant et coopératif comme son
l'indique aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit
c'est que le besoin d'investissement
équilibre financier difficile à trouver
c'est un modèle économique très
consommateur de ressources si je peux
dire mais les tâches mobilisent puisque
la Caisse des Dépôts elle-même appui et
travaille avec cette entreprise pour les
aider à boucler leur financement et
raycoop a déjà je l'ai évoqué aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale a déjà manifesté
son intérêt on verra si c'est solide et
crédible pour des lignes ouvertes à la
concurrence et donc là aussi dans la
calendrier d'ouverture qui portait à la
fois sur la grande vitesse comme vous le
savez sur certaines lignes de Tet du
côté de l'État et du côté des régions
sur les TER cela peut être un opérateur
complémentaire avec d'autres des
opérateurs étrangers je pense que cette
concurrence bien encadrée parce que ce
n'est pas la loi de la jambe très
encadrée des cahiers des charges définis
soit par les tâches soit par les régions
est aussi une facteur un facteur de
développement de l'offre ferroviaire
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
peut faire partie de ses acteurs il faut
simplement vérifier ça sa solidité
financière et la compagnie sur des
questions que vous avez posées monsieur
gilet je crois sur
sur GPSO et les financements européens
et sur la vie du Conseil d'État pour
être tout à fait pas connaissance de
l'engagement de mon prédécesseur sur ce
sujet vous faites bien de me le rappeler
je vous fais confiance
connaissez les conditions le publication
des avis il faut que l'autorisation en
effet gouvernementale je n'ai pas de je
n'ai pas d'objection à ce à cette
publication si tel engagement a été pris
je le vérifierai dans les prochaines les
prochains jours et nous mettrons en
oeuvre l'engagement pris au titre de la
continuité nécessaire de l'État sur les
financements européens puisque
effectivement sur GPSO je veux être le
plus précis possible j'en ai parlé
plusieurs fois notamment avec le
président Rousset
il est évident je vais le dire comme ça
ça fera plaisir à la Rousset que
tant qu'on a que c'est plus facile
d'avoir du financement européen s'il y a
une dimension transfrontalière
par nature je peux comprendre les règles
européennes cet égard et donc que on est
en parallèle du bord de Toulouse des
engagements sur Bordeaux Dax et sur une
un projet transfrontalier j'ai porté ce
sujet à auprès de la commissaire
européenne parce que je dis qu'il faut
pas que le mieux soit l'ennemi du bien
on a un projet qui est en train d'être
déployé qui est financé avec une société
de projet qui va voir ses premiers
ressources affectées si le Parlement
décide ainsi dès 2023 donc le projet est
concret sur bord de Toulouse il est
évidemment plus mûr la partie
d'aménagement dans l'agglomération
bordelaise servira de toute façon à
l'ensemble des deux branches du projet
donc la dimension européenne me semble
c'est un peu circulaire si on n'a pas
une aide financière européenne sur les
aménagements de Bordeaux ce que j'ai
essayé de plaider auprès de la
commissaire européenne
fragilise un peu le projet même s'il
sera au rendez-vous nous serons au
rendez-vous je vais revenir sur la part
de l'État donc pour être clair nous
n'avons pas encore de réponse européenne
définitive même sur la première branche
du projet nous plaidons pour que dès le
début de ce projet puisse être éligible
les financements européens il est
évident que plus on donnera de garanties
sur Bordeaux Dax plus on aura le chance
d'avoir un financement européen élevé
pour être très clair mais ça n'est pas
une condition qui a été posée comme
sinequanone par la Commission européenne
donc moi je suis optimiste sur la
mobilisation de financement européen
pour GPSO pour le dire comme ça
si les financements ne sont pas à la
hauteur ou plus tardif qu'est-ce qu'on
fait les deux peuvent arriver
je vais être honnête il faudra qu'on
discute des clés de financement mais
l'État n'a pas vocation à prendre tout
le risque à chaque fois donc il faudra
que ça soit un effort financier partagé
comme on le fait depuis le départ mais
je veux pas me situer dans cette optique
pessimiste parce que s'il n'y a pas eu
de réponse positive sur le dernier appel
à projet c'est parce que notre
calendrier était plus tardif que
beaucoup de projets qui ont reçu un
financement européen de la part du MMI
pardon voilà donc je le sais mais je
pourrais être publiquement transparent
je vous dis ma vision de des choses je
réponds au sénateur gold qui a dû nous
quitter sur la question de Clermont le
pari clairement j'y reviens pas en
détail sur les transports innovants on a
effectivement un certain nombre de
financements qui ont été mobilisés dans
le contexte notamment de France 2030 il
y a un total de 200 millions
d'investissements sur des projets
innovants de transport en commun
terrestre qui ont été mobilisés donc oui
c'est une un des axes que l'État veut
t'encourager et moi je veux qu'on
développe le soutien des solutions de
financement une solution de innovante
pardon notamment matière de transport
autonome il y en a une qui est financée
par l'ADEME par exemple dans l'Inde qui
est un cas unique en France de transport
autonome en zone rural typiquement c'est
je pense un facteur de désenclavagement
un facteur d'innovation qui ne doit pas
être au service que des grandes
agglomérations et donc dans nos
financements France 2030 ou Adem on doit
soutenir c'est transports en commun
innovant qui peuvent apporter les
solutions complémentaires
sur la question
du leasing et du biogène
sénateur
sur la question du leasing d'abord pour
être
revenir d'un mot sur ce sujet je l'ai
dit on travaille avec une Espagnole sa
mise en place d'ici la fin d'année je le
dis très franchement ce sera forcément
progressif parce que il faut qu'il y a
une offre industrielle française ou
européenne à minima qui soit disponible
et je pense encore une fois qu'on doit
mettre l'accent sur sa dispositif
complémentaire au financement existant
pour le passage électrique sur les zones
rurales notamment si on est dans une
logique d'expérimentation ou de premier
défunt le première phase de déploiement
pardon en 2023
sur les bio GNV
il faut s'assurer d'abord la
disponibilité dans les semaines qui
viennent dans les mois qui viennent
puisqu'on a quelques inquiétudes pour
les petites communes le bouclier
énergétique qui a été annoncé par la
première ministre fera partie des
solutions qu'on peut déployer et je
rappelle aussi parce que ça a été voté
cet été parce que c'est important nous
avons autorisé les transporteurs
à répercuter le prix des énergies
alternatives donc y compris le biogène V
dans le coup facturé au chargeur pour
que le rapport de force économique en
quelque sorte souhaite en partie
rééquilibrer
la modalités je
j'intègre d'ailleurs dans cette
réflexion ensemble toute une continuité
port axe fluvio et potentiellement
dernier kilomètre en routier ou être
mission a été confiée d'ailleurs au
préfet de région en maillots par le
premier République quand il a présenté
le projet Marseille en grand par exemple
pour qu'on réfléchisse sur le
les connexions
port maritimes fluviales ferroviaire et
routier et il y aura un rapport d'ici la
fin de l'année sur ce sujet là ici sur
l'axe rhodanien principalement mais cela
peut être un modèle qu'on développe et
dans les contrats de plan et ta région
je pense que ces interconnexions doivent
être aussi renforcés
pour vous donner quelques illustrations
sur
les ports fluviaux de ce que le plan de
relance en particulier a financé ou est
en train de financer l'électrification
des quais dans les dans le transport
fluvial dans les ports fluviaux
l'aménagement de l'infrastructure
fluviale dans les zones pour les zones
urbaines denses et le volet fluvial du
plan de relance finance aussi je
cherchais le chiffre 175 millions
d'euros d'investissement sur la
régénération des infrastructures
fluviales en complément d'ici 2024 pour
donner quelques illustrations chiffrées
sur ce que vous avez dit Monsieur
devinez sur le financement européen là
aussi mais cette fois sur le lion Turin
alors pour être très clair là-dessus et
après je viens au Céphale
quand on est en face d'étude le droit
commun européen c'est d'avoir jusqu'à
50% de financement
ce que la Commission européenne a dit
qui a été vu comme une sorte de date
limite qui était pas aussi précise que
ça c'est que si on vous choisissez
rapidement le scénario des accès sur
quel que soit le scénario d'ailleurs
nous pourrions être éligibles dans le
prochain appel à projet à 50% de
financement mais ce que je pense la
Commission européenne n'avait pas
regardé de près c'est que quoi qu'il
arrive quel que soit le scénario gang
gabarit qui serait une finie retenue
nous le demandeurions pour les
prochaines années des financements
uniquement sur des études puisqu'on
commencera par une phase d'étude et donc
cette majoration du taux est en quelque
sorte inopérante puisque de toute façon
nous serons dans le droit commun des
taux de financement le cofinancement à
50%. j'espère être clair c'est pour ça
que je veux dire qu'il n'y a pas à mon
sens d'urgence majeure
au regard des règles européennes au
regard des financements européens à
prendre notre décision sur le scénario
sur le toute façon ce que nous
demandions à l'Europe ce sont des
financements d'études et de toute façon
les financements d'études sont à 50%. ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut procrastiner
parce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
pas de temps pour l'Europe que pour
nous-même il faut qu'on prenne une
décision rapide sur la question des
accès dans le scénario grand gabarit
notamment vous le savez ce qui fait
d'ailleurs une partie de son coût élevé
c'est qu'il est sur une porte sur les
accès eux-mêmes mais aussi sur le
Cephale Nord et donc c'est intégré dans
le scénario un peu plus de 10 milliards
d'euros ça prend en compte aussi pardon
le financement du Céphale Nord scénario
qui est a été testé par le préfet de
région après des collectivités locales
pour reprendre la métaphore anatomique
monsieur le sénateur jeunesse sur
je ne sais pas si vous avez prévu que je
reparle de colonne vertébrale et que
l'intervention était ainsi faite mais
s'il a été ajusté je suis encore plus
impressionné
alors sur les normes sur les normes sur
les normes
OMS
la directive européenne qui a été de
l'air visait justement enfin vise
puisque les plusieurs à rapproché au fur
et à mesure de ses générations les
normes le concentration vers les normes
au ms pardon nous n'avons on va voir
l'OMS va sans doute renforcé encore ses
normes et ça aurait pu le droit européen
enfin pas sans doute comme il l'a fait à
plusieurs reprises européens devra s'y
adapter donc on n'a pas encore pris de
position mais la France va défendre
évidemment à chaque fois le suivi par le
droit européen des normes OMS duquel
international donc
déjà essayons de mobiliser tous les
outils pour respecter les normes
européennes actuelles c'est normo MS
évolue le droit européen évoluera et
nous ferons tout pour nous y conformer
comme nous avons essayé de le faire
notamment par la politique de ZFE
puisque c'est aussi une réponse à cela
dans les dernières années et elle se
déplo en ce moment sur la colonne
vertébrale vous avez évoqué clairement
c'est pas ça rentre dans la catégorie à
l'os je souhaite que non mais je crois
avoir le instant d'éléments j'insiste
beaucoup sur cette ligne je sais que
c'est difficile je sais qu'il y a eu en
plus des événements exceptionnels comme
l'incident si je peux dire du 20 juillet
avec un 19 juin avec un retard total de
20 heures
c'est envoyé a été amical en disant 16
heures je crois que c'était même 20h
heureusement c'est très exceptionnel
heureusement la régularité c'est plutôt
amélioré sur l'année 2022
mais j'insiste parce que c'est pas une
coquetterie je crois que cette ligne
comme Paul's est très emblématique
d'abord les efforts financiers j'en ai
pas le mérite ils ont décidé avant que
j'arrive qui sont engagés par l'État qui
ont parfois pris un peu de retard c'est
vrai mais qui sont quand même la
meilleure réponse à des lignes qui
étaient en difficulté et sur lesquelles
on n'est pas investi souvent depuis 40
ans à la fois sur le réseau et sur les
nouvelles RAM et je ferai tout pour que
même si dans la période actuelle nous
avons des retards industriels pas que
sur ce projet malheureusement nous les
limitions le plus possible et c'est le
redis je verrai notamment le PDG de CAF
dans les jours qui viennent sur
sur parre et Lyon quelques mots de
calendrier
que je cherche à retrouver pour ne pas
vous dire de bêtises
mais plus sous les yeux
sinon j'y reviens dans un instant
j'y reviendrai tout de suite je me suis
obligatoire sur le faire routage et sur
Paris Normandie sur le fer routage il y
a trois axes sur lequel nous avons un
calendrier de déploiement à la fois sept
Calais en quelques mois cette Valenton
objectif début 2023 et Cherbourg
moughers fin 2024 c'est dans la
stratégie nationale le Fred ferroviaire
que nous avons intégré je l'ai dit hier
je le redis parce que je le pense
profondément ça fait le lien d'ailleurs
est-ce qu'on disait sur le fluvial
au-delà du parmi parce que c'est une des
solutions mais du ce qu'on entend
souvent par le fret for le par le Féro
le Fred ferroviaire c'est à dire le fer
routage à mettre un camion sur un train
nous devons aussi dans les stratégie
fret renforcée un certain nombre de
liens qui sont pas forcément mettre un
camion sur un train des containers de
manière plus générale type
désengorgement de nos ports je pense à
la sortie de fosse je pense à la sortie
de Dunkerque ou dans les contrats de
prorat de ta région je pense que le
nouveau maître conformément la stratégie
nationale de Fred ferroviaire des moyens
importants pour renforcer si je puis
dire l'évacuation par fret ferroviaire
sur Paris Normandie vous le savez dans
les étapes je sais que c'est un long
feuilleton mais que les études
préalables pardon à l'enquête publique
sont en cours que dans le séquencement
la priorité que nous continuons à donner
c'est le noeud Paris Saint-Lazare et que
nous avons aussi beaucoup
d'infrastructures sur lesquelles les
financements doivent être sécurisés
mobilisés lire nouvelle à Rouen et là
aussi à partir je ne mets pas toute la
pression des travaux du coi nous
engagerons dans la nouvelle génération
de contrats de plan est à région un
certain nombre de financements d'études
ou projets concrets sur la période qui
s'ouvre l'an prochain donc je crois que
nous franchirons je sais que c'est
parfois un peu long mais un certain
nombre un certain nombre d'étapes sur
pareil Lyon pardon j'y reviens je
cherchais les chiffres exacts pour la
première opération de rénovation de 2017
c'était près de 45 millions d'euros
entre le CPER Bourgogne Franche-Comté le
CPR Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
[Musique]
la nouvelle opération de rénovation est
prévue en 2025 et les études
préparatoires sont en cours de
financement maintenant ce qui va être
très important c'est là aussi le
prochain CPV et pardon il y a un système
est de s'inscrire dans le cadre du
protocole petite ligne puisque nous
attendons nous souhaitons toujours que
la participation de la région vers le
Rhône-Alpes cette définir dans ce
cadre-là le montant de la participation
de l'État on a identifié un total de 17
millions d'euros le montant de la
participation de l'État n'a pas été
défini parce qu'on attend la signature
aussi de ce protocole mais donc l'état
est prêt à se mobiliser nous l'avons
fait dans le cadre des CPR précédent
pour l'opération de 2017 les études
préparatoires nous avons co-financé je
vous retrouve là aussi les chiffres
c'était sur un total d'un million cinq
400.000 euros de l'État et le
financement que nous pourrions engager
en 2023 pour les travaux eux-mêmes après
les études cette nouvelle phase c'est 17
millions d'euros l'État est prêt à
prendre sa part et prêt à discuter avec
la région des clés de financement
puisque c'est une section qui est situé
sur le territoire de la Région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes
oui mais
totalement l'excès
dernier point pardon je n'oublie la
reine 88 et les
chartes courtes talents je crois sur
lesquels je vous dois cet homme de
précision sur charte courtalin le besoin
de financement je vérifie le chiffre
identifier de 17 millions d'euros
pour SNCF réseau le montant qui serait
mobilisé c'est 1,4 milliards d'euros et
là aussi la pareta pour être apporté
dans le CPER et est identifié autour de
5 millions d'euros aujourd'hui pour
apprendre à Monsieur Anglard sur la RN
elle fait partie vous le savez des
tronçons que avec des projets que dans
le CPR
Occitanie nous regardons avec attention
là aussi la négociation va s'engager sur
la suite il faut qu'on trouve un
équilibre état région comme c'est
naturel et il faut je me permets
d'insister aussi
si ce n'est pas strictement un
cosignataire du contrat de plan et ta
région que nous associions pris
peut-être financièrement le département
de l'Aveyron voilà pour être le plus
précis possible sur ce projet mais je
l'ai bien identifié et ça n'a pas
échappé non plus la préfecture dans son
premier recensement dans le cadre du CPR
et de son prochain volet mobilité
pault pour changer un peu de Paris
Clermont
je sais qu'il y a des difficultés de
même nature en réalité et pour cause les
rames sont aussi anciennes et le réseau
également c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on
fait un investissement parallèle qui est
sensiblement proportionnellement le même
1,6 milliards d'euros mobilisés 1,9
milliards d'euros par non mobilisés par
l'État y compris SNCF réseau
sur la ligne POLT j'étais pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de jalousie si je puis dire
avant même mon déplacement à
Clermont-Ferrand à Châteauroux
précisément le 22 août dernier
nous avons discuté de la livraison des
nouvelles RAM je ne cacherai rien je le
dis aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas le
chiffrage exact des retards potentiels
sur la livraison des rames mais je peux
vous dire deux choses d'abord je vais
essayer de faire en sorte que la
livraison commence le plus proche
possible l'échéance qui était prévu à
partir de 2024 que la fin du calendrier
de livraison sur les deux lignes puisque
ce sont les mêmes rames soit le plus
près possible du respect des engagements
pris c'est-à-dire 2026 peut-être un
glissement le quelques mois mais je
pense qu'on peut le réduire vraiment à
quelques mois et pas le chiffrer en
année donc on parle de quelques mois je
pense qu'à terminaison de la livraison
des rames on peut être beaucoup plus
près les échanges prévus qu'au début
c'est peut-être au début de la livraison
qu'on peut avoir quelques retards je
sais qu'il y a l'échéance des Jeux
Olympiques soyons honnêtes toutes les
nouvelles RAM quoi qu'il arrive ne
seront pas disponibles et les travaux ne
seront pas entièrement
réalisé ça c'est très clair en revanche
je l'ai dit aussi à Clermont-Ferrand si
nos premières rats arrivent je souhaite
qu'il y a un équilibre parce que certes
il y a les chances olympiques mais je
voudrais pas qu'on crée je ne serais
objectivement pas le justifier un
déséquilibre dans la livraison de l'eram
puisque tout ne se fera pas d'un coup
entre Paris Clermont et Paul's bon je le
dis aussi en toute sincérité après il y
a une question d'offre le transport en
général sur laquelle j'aurais changerai
avec le président de la métropole en
particulier pour les Jeux Olympiques qui
est local mais qui est aussi national
pour que nous ayons notre bonne
condition j'ai parlé de transports en
Île-de-France il y a d'autres sites
olympiques château où on fait partie
pour que nous ayons une offre
exceptionnelle pour les Jeux Olympiques
qui puisse être une des certes de bonne
qualité c'est un site qui sera
regardé et qui doit avoir une offre de
transport depuis Paris notamment de
bonne qualité donc ça ne préjugue pas de
la transformation structurelle mais je
serai j'y serai attentif et le
calendrier de livraison exacte des rames
puisque à la ligne Paul d'un avantage
sur Paris Clermont c'est que nous
n'avons pas le problème supplémentaire
de l'autorité environnementale
sur ce point précis je vous donnerai les
précisions d'ici la fin de l'année après
les échanges avec l'industriel en
essayant de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
le moins de décalage possible
ai-je oublié pardon
sur Oui Bourges Montluçon et vous m'avez
interrogé aussi sur la mobilité
oui pardon en fait sur pocle
bon là vous savez qu'on parle de plus
long terme
donc pardon
ouais je sais mais je préfère être être
honnête je leur enverrai pas cette fois
aux travaux du coi ce serait malvenu
enfin on ne parle pas d'un projet autant
là la rénovation de la ligne de POLT j'y
suis engagé j'espère qu'on aura des
délais là on parle d'un horizon qui est
sans doute au-delà de la prochaine
décennie si on est tout à fait honnête
donc voilà
je ferai pas aujourd'hui de plan sur la
comète ce serait exagérée mais de
calendrier précis même si je sais que
c'est une discussion de longue date
j'en ai là aussi et puisqu'on parle de
Paris Orléans Clermont Lyon par les à
Clermont-Ferrand je suis presque on
réenvisage un calendrier des études qui
avaient déjà été largement faite mais on
ne parle pas de quelque chose de de
proche
sur Bourges Montluçon c'est assez
emblématique là aussi de la revalité de
la revitalisation pardon des petites
lignes il y a un protocole d'accord en
l'espèce entre l'État et centre Val de
Loire qui définit une stratégie un
financement sur 10 ans et des tas
finances j'insiste parce que c'est un
taux de financement très important les
investissements ne régénération de la
ligne à hauteur de 90% même un peu plus
de 90% avec les travaux qui commencent
enfin qui seront à réaliser en 2023 et
une partie en région en
région pardon
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes qui elle est
évaluée à 29 millions d'euros avec une
par étape de la moitié
le montant de travaux je ne l'ai plus
exactement
ça je vous le communiquerai parce que
pardon on achète 2021 mais c'est pas
c'est pas la bonne réponse
alors je vous le communiquerai
exactement pour pas vous dire de bêtises
parce que je n'ai plus en tête de
mémoire c'était 20 millions en 2021 mais
je vous le voulez les chiffres 2023 plus
précisément pour lever le flou
voilà pardon je vous apporterai cette
précision le plus rapidement possible et
j'oubliais quelques sujets monsieur le
Président et Monsieur monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi de vous demander de
refaire un petit détour par
l'Eure-et-Loir sur l'hydrogène parce que
vous m'avez donné une précision sur le
contrat de plan de la ligne
charpourtalin mais ça c'est quelque
chose qui est en cours et mon souci est
justement que les lignes qui font
l'objet aujourd'hui de contrat de plan
qui sont diesel on en a deux en
Eure-et-Loir Chartres pardon Paris tour
Châteaudun et Chartres Alain ne fasse
pas l'objet dans quelques années d'une
menace de fermeture parce qu'elles
seront diesel et parce que la SNCF aura
décidé de passer au tout hydrogène c'est
tout c'est je voulais qu'on revienne un
petit peu sur cette question d'hydrogène
suite à l'audition de Jean-Pierre
farando merci
il est certainement pas qu'on est comme
une sorte de double pelle c'est à dire
qu'on n'est pas de soutien pour passer
notre technologie et que on est une
fermeture parce qu'on leur sera pas
passé une nouvelle technologie donc là
aussi je suis prêt à regarder les
modalités de financement pour une
solution qui aujourd'hui commence à se
déployer et nous avons en plus
l'industriel qui est le plus avancé en
la matière donc je veux bien regarder
les modes de financement et le
calendrier qu'on pourrait avoir là
dessus
mais oui
[Musique]
changement de carburant vous avez
tout à l'heure pour la décarbonation en
général on a on a trois axes pour que
les modes de vol si je peux dire soit
les plus propres possibles on sait bien
que en tout cas pour les grands Porsche
pour les gros porteurs électriques
hydrogène c'est pas pour tout de suite
et donc on a on va mettre l'accent sur
les carburants carburant de synthèse
biocarburant là-dessus je le redis comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure on est le
premier pays à avoir défini des normes
1% à ce stade aujourd'hui pour l'année
prochaine on définit les de leurs au
niveau européen je redonne la
trajectoire qui est aujourd'hui prévue
parce que le texte est encore en
discussion au niveau européen entre le
Parlement et le Conseil ça serait
vraisemblablement
6% en 2030
peut-être un peu plus enfin c'est pour
l'instant la fourchette haute la
discussion
et le sujet central c'est que nous avons
besoin de cette référence pour
encourager une offre sinon nous n'aurons
jamais et nous aurons besoin aussi sur
les biocarburants particulièrement
d'avoir dans les feuilles de route
je reviens au niveau national de
l'article 300 la loi qui m'a résilience
qui secteur par secteur définira les
priorités de décarbonation il faudra
qu'on fasse des priorités d'usage parce
que des biocarburants il y en aura sans
doute pas pour tous les usages pour
lesquels on peut l'envisager parce qu'en
priorise l'aviation est-ce qu'on
priorise la modification d'un certain
nombre de camions etc il faut apprendre
choisisse et évidemment prioriser sur
les deux carburants les secteurs
laquelle nous n'avons pas l'alternative
prolon les avions seront une des
priorités à cet égard sur les vols
d'aviation sur les vols d'aviation
privée sur les mesures qui sont
envisagées les pistes sur lesquelles
aujourd'hui nous travaillons il y a je
crois qu'un amendement était d'ailleurs
déposé par vos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale
la question de la TICPE qui est plutôt
je le disais tout à l'heure une forme de
rééquilibrage
décide d'assemblée nationale ça n'est
pas dans le PLF mais il y a déjà moins
ce sens
parce que
la TCP a été relevée dans la loi de
finance pour 2021 de mémoire mais
davantage elle est aujourd'hui plus
élevée sur des usages
d'aviation privée non commerciaux et
d'aviation de loisirs que sur l'aviation
privée commerciale ce qu'on appelle
d'habitude budget privé c'est l'aviation
privée commerciale non commercialement
elle a un avantage fiscal par rapport à
l'aviation de loisirs par exemple des
petits aéroclubs ou à de l'aviation
privée commerciale type transfert
sanitaire etc ce qui est assez difficile
à expliquer ça c'est une première piste
nous avons sur au plan européen pardon
deux textes qui sont en discussion
un que je viens d'évoquer sur les
carburants les fameux safs et les 6%
d'incorporation en 2030 c'est un texte
encore en discussion je le disais il
laissera vraisemblablement cette en tout
cas ce que la France défend la
possibilité
d'élargir le socle de règle européenne
avec ce qu'on appelle un opt-in en bon
français ou mauvais français les petits
aéroports et notamment les aéroports
d'affaires donc les États membres
pourront dire les 6% par exemple pour
2030 il ne s'applique pas seulement à
certains grands aéroports c'est ça qui
est prévu dans le cadre européen mais
ils peuvent s'appliquer à beaucoup
d'autres aéroports les plus petits des
aéroports d'affaires en particulier donc
ça c'est une mesure aussi qui sera les
saisons la discrétion des États membres
de leur texte européen que nous pourrons
activer qui est important je pense par
souci d'équité et puis il y a un texte
européen plus général sur l'aviation qui
est une directive
sur la taxation d'énergie et qui porte
le sujet de la fin de l'exemption
kérosène alors ça ça ne porte pas que
sur l'aviation privée mais ça la
concerne aussi vous savez que au terme
d'une convention internationale ancienne
le kérosène est exempté dans l'aviation
le taxation
il n'y a pas de dérogation possible sauf
pour les vols intérieurs et donc si on
veut avoir une exemple si on a du sens
c'est de l'impact il vaut mieux la faire
sur l'espace européen dans son ensemble
l'Europe peut décider que sur les vols
intérieurs à l'espace européen il y a
une exemption il y a une il n'y a pas
d'exemption du kérosène il y a une
dérogation à l'exemption du kérosène
c'est un texte qui est défendu par le
gouvernement français qui a été proposé
par la Commission européenne et qui est
en cours de discussion au niveau
européen dernier point
pour être complet il y a une discussion
qui est encore en train d'être finalisée
sur le système dit ets au niveau
européen qui imposera les obligations
renforcées de coûts à carbone à
l'aviation et qui pourrait c'est un des
éléments de discussion qui est en cours
avoir une différenciation entre certains
segments de l'aviation privée l'aviation
commerciale plus classique voilà pour
les pistes bien monsieur le ministre
merci
pour cet échange merci pour vos réponses
très précises merci à mes collègues qui
sont restés jusqu'au bout de cette
audition et puis on aura l'occasion de
vous revoir pour le parler un peu budget
et autres et puis merci pour votre
disponibilité parce que vous m'avez on
s'est rencontré et puis m'avait reçu et
on a un autre rendez-vous merci pour
votre écoute
beaucoup et je le redis je suis
évidemment pour précision sujet plus
précis ainsi que mon cabinet toujours à
votre disposition de l'anneau
rendez-vous en audition pour préciser ou
compléter certains points